zdf heute live herzlich willkommen nach
dem trial ist vor dem schlagabtausch
nachdem sich gestern die drei
kanzlerkandidatin und die kandidaten
hier im zdf und auch in der idee den
fragen der journalisten gestellt haben
und einen schlagabtausch geliefert haben
kommt heute hier der schlagabtausch der
anderen im bundestag vertretenen
parteien afd fdp csu und linke streiten
miteinander und stellen sich den fragen
von zdf politik chef matthias fornoff
wir streamen das live in wenigen minuten
wollen aber erst noch mal ein bisschen
auf die ausgangslage gucken und auf die
parteien und was sie sich denn so
vorstellen könnten und wie sie
aufgestellt sind
ampel rot grün rot oder vielleicht doch
jamaika klar ist nach der bundestagswahl
könnten viele farbkombinationen an die
macht führen wahrscheinlich aus drei
parteien besonders gefragt ist in diesen
tagen die fdp die liberalen könnten zum
königsmacher werden entweder für armin
laschet in einem jamaika-bündnis oder
für olaf scholz in einer ampelkoalition
die fdp will sich noch nicht festlegen
aber
wir haben eine präferenz für jamaika
selbstverständlich gar keine frage wir
haben ein sehr gutes
vertrauensverhältnis steht
nordrhein-westfalen wir selbst mit den
grünen gemeinsam entstehen in schleswig
holstein und der union auch die linken
scheinen wieder im rennen zu sein nach
den jetzigen zahlen könnte es für rot
grün rot reichen es gibt viele
gemeinsamkeiten im parteiprogramm aber
spd kandidat scholz will von den linken
ein bekenntnis zur nato das gibt es
bisher nicht nicht viel voneinander
bekenntnisse zu verlangen wir haben ja
gerade gesehen das scheitern der nato in
afghanistan
und ich bin eigentlich der meinung dass
jetzt mal die parteien die die
bundeswehr dorthin geschickt haben in
diesen auslandseinsatz nochmal
reflektieren sollten ob es eine richtige
entscheidung war wir sind der meinung
dass es nicht so war außerdem möglich
eine deutschland koalition aus spd und
union
fdp oder ein kenia bündnis spd union und
grüne die farbspiele laufen in berlin
auf hochtouren nur mit der afd möchte
niemand koalieren
tja so weit also dieses tableau von
christian volk wir werden gleich sehen
mit welchen inhalten die parteien
punkten wollen in ungefähr naja knapp
fünf minuten sind wir dabei wenn es in
die diskussion geht in berlin adlershof
und
wie immer ihre und eure fragen in die
kommentare oder wenn ihr und sie die
zdf- heute- app nutzt bitte die
eingeblendete e-mail-adresse benutzen
wir sind heute abend hier nicht alleine
sondern haben die
politikwissenschaftlerin professor
andrea römmele mit im boot zugeschaltet
aus mannheim schönen guten namen frau
professor remmele ich bin sicher sie
haben gestern das trial geguckt heute
nun also der schlagabtausch der kleinen
parteien und das ist ja insofern wichtig
als wir nicht den kanzler wählen oder
die kanzlerin sondern ein neues
parlament also auch über diese parteien
entscheiden die sich heute abend im
schlagabtausch stellen was erwarten sie
heute
ja genau so ist es ihr wählen parteien
und eben nicht einen kanzler oder eine
kanzlerin
ich erwarte einen vielleicht etwas
inhalts reicheren und pointierten
abschlag als wir es gestern abend
gesehen haben aber
natürlich auch dass sich die partei
einigermaßen offen in unterschiedliche
richtungen präsentieren wir haben es ja
auch gerade in ihrem beitrag gesehen
unterschiedliche koalitionsoptionen
unterschiedlichen farbspiele sind
möglich und jeder möchte sich natürlich
hier so lange wie möglich im rennen
halten jetzt haben wir auch am
wochenende erlebt schon beim csu
parteitag am samstag hat sich armin
laschet kämpferisch gezeigt gestern
wurde auch schon mit härteren bandagen
gekämpft als beim tri l vor zwei wochen
was erwarten sie von heute wird da auch
noch mal die schraube ein bisschen
nachgedreht der ton schärfer
ja ich erwarte mir ein
einen lebendigen einen lebhaften
schlagabtausch bei dem ersten trial
standen ja die drei spitzenkandidaten
und die spitzenkandidatin ja dass sich
das erste mal gegenüber
teilweise auch angeschlagen schon vom
wahlkampf also gerade annalena baerbock
und armin laschet hatten ja doch auch
einiges einzustecken gehabt davor die
kandidaten und kandidatinnen die wir
jetzt zehn stehen ja nicht ganz so in
der medialen beobachtung im wahlkampf
wie die spitzenkandidaten es tun
insofern erwarte ich mir auch ein
bisschen eine freiere und vielleicht
auch ein bisschen eine lebendigere
diskussion was die themen angeht damit
festgestellt es gab viel kritik an der
sendung gestern dass zum beispiel die
themen außenpolitik afghanistan europa
gar nicht angesprochen wurden wenn man
sich die zahlen anguckt dann sagen viele
befragte vom politbarometer zuletzt
wichtig für meine wahlentscheidung ist
vor allem soziale gerechtigkeit sagen 51
prozent klimaschutz sagen 39 corona 23
und flüchtlinge asyl 21 über welche
themen müsste denn dringend gesprochen
werden ja ich denke schon das
außenpolitische themen auch ganz zentral
sind und gerade es ist ja wir haben sie
auch in ihrem beitrag gesehen dass
gerade die außenpolitische positionen
der linken das nicht bekenntnis zur nato
ein ganz großer knackpunkt ist
afghanistan ist ein großes thema also
ich denke schon dass hier auf auch die
sprache kommen wird aber natürlich sind
es auch die themen die wir gestern
gehört haben also die kleineren parteien
leben ja nicht in einer völlig anderen
welt und haben deswegen völlig andere
themen es geht ja hier um die gleichen
themen sie werden andere
lösungsvorschläge
haben aber dass ich jetzt dass wir ein
ganzheitlich anderes themen tableau
sehen dass wir sicherlich nicht
passieren dann sind wir gespannt was es
gleich geht wir werden danach
miteinander in diana diese gehen vielen
dank frau professor rummel bis dahin und
wir blicken schon mal nach berlin es ist
nicht adlershof wie ich
fälschlicherweise gerade gesagt habe das
war gestern heute die sendung kommt aus
dem hauptstadtstudio und da sehen wir
noch nicht so wahnsinnig viel das ist
das startbild was sie gleich begrüßen
wird bevor es losgeht
moderation wie gesagt matthias vorne auf
unserer politik chef und mit dabei
wolfgang kubicki von der fdp der
stellvertretende parteivorsitzende
janine wissler von der linken die
parteivorsitzende markus blume der
generalsekretär der csu und alice seidel
von der afg die ko vorsitzende der
bundestagsfraktion und in wenigen
sekunden geht es los und damit geben wir
hier ab nach berlin viel spaß
[Musik]
guten abend und herzlich willkommen zum
schlagabtausch dem politischen vierkampf
am tag nach dem trial sie erleben den
meinungsstreit der anderen im bundestag
vertretenen parteien die keinen eigenen
kanzlerkandidaten stellen die debatte
hier verspricht spannend zu werden denn
die ausgangslage ist offen wie schon
lange nicht und gerade die sogenannten
kleineren parteien könnten am ende das
zünglein an der waage sein deshalb freue
ich mich auf unsere gäste heute hier
abend und das sind
für die afg tritt an die
spitzenkandidatin alice seidel
die stimme der fdp der stellvertretende
bundesvorsitzende wolfgang kubicki
für die linke dabei
spitzenkandidatin janine wissler
und die csu wird vertreten durch
generalsekretär markus blume
sie alle sind zu gast im schlagabtausch
bei matthias fornoff
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen
klima und umwelt rente bezahlbares
wohnen steuern das sind themen die die
wahl mit entscheiden könnten überall das
wollen wir reden in der nächsten stunde
wir bieten übrigens auch diesmal wieder
einen faktencheck an die kolleginnen und
kollegen überprüfen strittige fragen und
aussagen aus dieser sendung und morgen
können sie die dann nachlesen in der
zdf- heute- app und damit gleich zu
unserem ersten thema das heißt corona
das robert koch institut warnt vor einer
fulminanten vierten welle und das thema
könnte entscheidend sein denn die
konzepte der parteien unterscheiden sich
deutlich doch zunächst die lage im
filmischen überblick
[Musik]
abstandsgebot hygieneregeln reise und
kontakt beschränkungen nie zuvor wurde
so stark in unser leben eingegriffen und
die folgen für wirtschaft und
gesellschaft sind noch lange nicht
absehbar vor allem für kinder und
jugendliche ist die belastung groß fast
jedes dritte kind zeige psychische
auffälligkeiten so eine aktuelle studie
schonungslos hat die pandemie außerdem
offen gelegt wo deutschland hinterher
hinkt mangelnde medizinische ausrüstung
fehlende pandemiepläne die schlechte
ausstattung an den schulen der immensen
nachholbedarf in sachen digitalisierung
und während das impf tempo nachlässt und
wir noch nicht wissen wie sich die
vierte welle entwickelt wächst erneut
die kritik an der regierung und ihrer
entscheidung die epidemische lage zu
verlängern fehlt uns also immer noch der
richtige plan für die pandemie
[Musik]
kritik an der regierung das stichwort
nämlich mal auf den wir haben ja hier am
pult jemanden dessen partei mitregiert
in berlin markus blume herzlich
willkommen die zahl der geimpften die
steigt ja zurzeit nur sehr langsam und
ist auch in bayern sogar niedriger als
bundesweit die impfquote welche idee
welches rezept haben sie denn um das im
bundesland bayern aber auch im bund zu
verbessern impfen ist unser einziges
ticket zur normalität wir müssen dankbar
sein dass wir diese möglichkeit jetzt
haben das ist ja der entscheidende
unterschied jetzt auch bei dieser
vierten welle wir hatten bei der ersten
zwei drei bälle eben keine impfung zur
verfügung deswegen waren dort nur andere
dinge möglich und deswegen ist jetzt die
bekämpfung der korona pandemien dieser
phase auch in keiner weise zu
vergleichen ich sage ganz deutlich wir
dürfen dankbar sein und stolz auf das
was wir in deutschland erreicht haben
wir sind besser durch die krise gekommen
als die meisten anderen länder auf der
welt was mich wirklich gekümmert sind
vertreter in dieser runde nicht so tun
als gäbe es corona gar nicht als gäbe es
keine pandemie als wäre es die ganz
normale grippe wir wissen das ist eben
nicht der fall und deswegen müssen wir
alles tun um die impfkampagne auch jetzt
entscheiden noch voranzubringen ich sage
es noch mal ganz deutlich wir sind gut
unterwegs aber wir müssen beim impfen
noch weiter kommen ich glaube frau beide
dass sie meinte deshalb gebe ich den
staffelstab man an sie weiter und frage
sie ihre partei fordert ja das ende der
masken pflicht gerade jetzt wo die
vierte welle bevorsteht herbst und
winter kommen mehr in den innenräumen
wieder spielt macht das wirklich sinn
also erstmal wollen wir die gesamte
corona maßnahmen debatte sachlicher
führen der lockt da und die gesamte
locker und politik ist völlig überzogen
schade der wirtschaft schade und sein
arbeitsplätzen schadet uns auch
gesellschaftspolitisch und wir sehen
dass wir begleiten das sehr sehr
kritisch dass die gesellschaft gespalten
wird in ungeimpfte und geimpfte das
impfzwang impliziter de facto ausgeübt
wird auf die ungeimpften das führt er
jetzt auch so weit dass ungeimpfte im
quarantäne fall keine lohnfortzahlung
erwarten dürfen und das halte ich für
völlig überrissen und auch für
verfassungswidrig die gerichte werden
sich damit beschäftigen müssen und der
staat darf keinen zwang ausüben auf eine
sehr persönliche entscheidung es ist die
abwägung zwischen dem nutzen und den
risiken einer impfung und das darf jeder
bürger für sich ganz frei entscheiden
und die familien für ihre kinder auch
die fdp herr kubicki sieht sich als
anwalt der freiheit den sachen corona
welche einschränkenden maßnahmen würden
sie dann gerne wegfallen lassen zunächst
mal ist es ein problem wenn ich nach der
auf die reden muss man das mal
klarzustellen dass wir nicht die gleiche
position wir halten das corona virus für
gefährlich wir wollen auch dass ich
möglichst viele menschen impfen lassen
aber man muss immer wissen
infektionsschutz ist gefahren hat mir
geht von menschen keine gefahr aus gibt
es auch keine rechtliche grundlage für
abwehrmaßnahmen das gilt sowohl für
genesene wie viele geimpfte wie
getestete westen schleswig holstein
beispielsweise anders als in bayern die
dreijährige gilt wie schafft man auch
die masten pflicht dort ab wo die 3g
regel eingehalten wird weil wenn wir
feststellen sind qualifizierten im raum
macht es auch keinen sinn maske zu
tragen aber gleichwohl würde ich alle
darum bitten auf sich selbst sagten
jeder für seine gesundheit selbst
verantwortlich wer sorgen hat sollte
maske tragen ich würde momentan in
großen innenräumen wenn ich auf leute
treffe die ich nicht kenne auch eine
maske tragen ich werbe für impfungen
aber ich akzeptiere auch dass menschen
aus welchen gründen auch immer das nicht
wollen dann müssen sie schlicht und
ergreifend sich regelmäßig testen das
nun ein letzter satz wenn diese
regierung schon feststellt was ich für
rechtlich fragwürdig halte das sieht bei
de mission lage das zu einer tragweite
weiter besteht dass also eine gefahr für
gesundheits system besteht dann macht es
keinen sinn test kostenpflichtig zu
machen denn dann ist ja unsere absicht
festzustellen wie das
infektionsgeschehen ist und da muss man
die tests eben nicht kostenpflichtig
machen sollen so viel wie möglich testen
und festzustellen wo ist das
infektionsgeschehen wo nicht ich läute
eine frau wissler ich würde gerne frau
wisla mit in die runde holen die linke
fordert ja mehr infektionsschutz auch in
den unternehmen und scharfe kontrollen
an den arbeitsplätzen sind sie dann
konsequenter auch dafür dass
arbeitnehmer abfragen dürfen ob ihre
mitarbeiterin mitarbeiter geimpft sind
so können hört könnte man ja
infektionsketten auch durchbrechen nein
da sind wir nicht dafür war dass es
wirklich gefährliche türöffner der zum
datenschutz hochproblematische fragen
aufwerfen würde da sind wir nicht dafür
aber dass die verantwortung ist
natürlich
unternehmer dass man
arbeitsschutzmaßnahmen ein held dass man
abstände einhält ich finde aber
insbesondere müssen wir jetzt über die
reden die wir ganz besonders schützen
müssen und das sind die die noch nicht
geimpft sind und das sind ganz besonders
die kinder und jugendlichen in den kitas
in den schulen wo wir gerade die
situation haben was wir in vielen
schulen auch keine luftfilter haben wo
die klassen zu groß sind wo die kinder
morgens sind voll gestopften schulbussen
zur schule fahren und wir wissen ja auch
wenn kinder in der regel nicht schwer
erkrankten also keine schweren verläufe
haben das longo wird auch ein thema bei
kindern also dass auch in den usa
beispielsweise kinder an cholera
gestorben sind von daher finde ich ist
ganz wichtig dass wir jetzt in den
schulen infektionsschutz maßnahmen
treffen die schülerinnen und schüler die
sowieso schon so gelitten haben in
dieser krise mit distanz unterricht mit
freizeit beschränkungen dass wir
wirklich auf die jetzt rücksicht nehmen
und die schützen weil für die gibt es
eben noch kein empfang geboten ich würde
mal eine frage in die runde werfen das
ist ja fakt dass diese corona pandemie
auch ein großes loch in die
staatshaushalte in die staatskasse
geschlagen hat man rede von ungefähr
geschätzten 650 milliarden euro das kann
auch leicht doppelt so viel sein wenn
man die staatsgarantien für unternehmen
die noch gar nicht abgeflossen sind mit
dazu zählt aber wer soll das bezahlen
fällt das auf die junge generation
zurück was sind da ihre rezepte
vielleicht darf man einfach mal zunächst
sagen deutschland hat in einem ausmaß
geholfen seine wirtschaftliche
betroffenen sektoren den betroffenen
betrieben dem betroffenen arbeitsplätzen
wie kein anderes land in europa
deutschland hat mehr hilfen aus gebracht
als alle anderen länder der eu zusammen
es ist eine gewaltige leistung und jetzt
kommt die richtungsentscheidung bei der
wir ja hier zur bundestagswahl stehen
wie kommen wir aus der krise und da gibt
es sehr unterschiedliche rezepte die
einen sagen von links schuldenbremse
kein problem die setzen wir quasi auf
dauer aus wollten sie ja im grunde schon
immer schleifen wir sagen wir müssen mit
neuem wachstum aus der krise deswegen
eine klare richtungsentscheidung auch
für entlastung um neuen schwung zu
nehmen und auch die wirtschaftlichen
kräfte zu stärken wir wollen aus der
krise heraus wachsen sowie das übrigens
nach der weltwirtschaftskrise im jahr
2009 auch gelungen ist
die kosten der krise durch eine
einmalige vermögensabgabe und das würde
die reichsten 0,7 in diesem land
betreffen eine einmalige vermögensabgabe
das gab es auch in der geschichte der
bundesrepublik geworden war und das auf
eine einmalige vermögensabgabe oder
betriebsvermögen und auf privates
vermögen wobei bei
privaten betreibern die grenze deutlich
höher wäre aber die frage ist ja am ende
wer soll das denn bezahlen die
alleinerziehende verkäuferin wird nicht
bezahlen können und wir haben jetzt
enorme kredite aufgenommen enorme kosten
gehabt die frage ist wie bezahlbares und
wir brauchen ja auch insgesamt höhere
investitionen deswegen schlagen wir auch
eine vermögenssteuer vor weil gerade
diese krise hat ja die missstände
gezeigt wir haben wir haben unter
finanziertes gesundheitssystem die
pflegekräfte sind überlastet und
verdienen zu wenig geld die schulen sind
und heim marode also die missstände in
dieser krise sind ja deutlich geworden
und deswegen sagen wir wir brauchen
dringend mehr geld aber für die
pflegekräfte wir brauchen mehr geld für
den ganzen öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst und da wollen wir
dringend in westen haselstrauch sie
trollenhagen mitgliedern frau weiter
folgen sie braucht man mehr geld sie
können vielleicht mal gelingt ja dann
sparen denken in bestimmten bereichen
bei 1 haben uns die letzten zehn jahre
gelernt und gelehrt hat der finanzkrise
durch eine starke wirtschaft sind wir
raus gewachsen aus der krise und nur
weil eine starke wirtschaft hatten
übrigens auch die aussage des
kanzlerkandidaten scholz haben wir die
leistung erbringen können während der
krise die wir erbracht haben irgendwie
650 milliarden euro sind inklusive der
europäischen aufbauhilfe also nicht das
was deutschland alleine für seine eigene
nation aufbringt es stimmt das
ifo-institut also untersucht werden wir
fünf jahre lang ein wirtschaftswachstum
von vier prozent hätten würden wir aus
der krise heraus lassen könnten wir die
pandemie schulden zurückzahlen und dass
irgendwas anderes passieren muss sie
müssen vielleicht ein bisschen
wirtschaftliches ein dynamischer prozess
und kein statisches verzog sie wollen ja
90 milliarden steuerentlastungen das
steht ja bei ihrer gramm ist das ist
weil er sparsam noch ist das in
irgendeiner form seriös das ist wirklich
finanzpolitisch motto was jemand machen
und deswegen muss ich mir glaube ich von
ihnen weil das einer währung
die nur an die mövenpick steuer und
anderes also fürs eigene klientel also
wenn sich wenn sie ja nun nicht so viel
von wirtschaft verstehen würden wer die
ddr nicht untergegangen so einfach ist
die frau weiter sie wollten sich gerade
schon melden wer zahlt die schulden wann
ist das ist die aufgabe der nächsten und
übernächsten generation oder geht es
auch anders
na gut also der deutsche staat war ja
vorher schon sehr hoch verschuldet das
kam jetzt noch als kloster mit dazu noch
eine anmerkung mit zusätzlichen steuern
vor allen dingen auch mit einer
vermögenssteuer sie haben ja auch gesagt
auf betriebsvermögen werden sie gar
nichts lösen die betriebe sind bereits
jetzt schon belastete mit einer
zusätzlichen vermögenssteuer jagen sie
diese betriebe in die insolvenz und in
den bankrott so dass keine lösung das
kontraproduktiv und herr blume hat ja
über das hervorragende management
gesprochen also das kann ich so nicht
sehen die korona hilfe kam für manche
betriebe viel zu spät man hat versucht
das problem zu lösen durch überrissene
maßnahme durch
berufsverbote im übrigen ist in unserem
grundgesetz in unserer verfassung die
berufsfreiheit verankert berufsverbote
sind verfassungswidrig das darf der
staat überhaupt nicht dass er menschen
an der arbeit hindert und da auch damit
werden sich gerichte beschäftigen müssen
was wir tun müssen nach vorne heraus ist
erstmal mit der angst und panikmache
aufhören wir müssen aufklären corona ist
gefährlich für bestimmte risikogruppen
für ältere menschen für menschen mit
herz-kreislauf-erkrankungen dort
brauchen wir hygiene konzepte
abstandsregelung die einzuhalten sind
und auch impfungen die funktionieren
denn was ich auch am imk markt
feststelle ist dass ausländische
wettbewerber rausgehalten werden
stichwort sputnik wehe der russische
hersteller von einem protein tod stoff
impfstoff der genauso funktioniert wie
ein grippeimpfstoff deutlich
verträglicher als direktor impfstoffe
oder die geben weil sie in impfstoffe
die wir jetzt haben wir brauchen mehr
wettbewerb auf dem stoffmarkt und
dementsprechend hätten wir dann auch ein
größeres angebot mehr wahlfreiheit für
die menschen da glücklicherweise sind ja
durch eine impfstoffe auch in
deutschland entwickelt worden wir haben
hier corona bedingt wie sie sicher
festgestellt haben kein publikum im
studio aber wir haben jede menge fragen
von zuschauerinnen und zuschauer am see
wir kommen und wir haben ein kleines
format werden das kreuzverhör jeder von
ihnen wird das einmal machen das ist
eine minute lang fragen von zuschauern
den zuschauer mit der bitte um kurze
präzise antworten dann kommen möglichst
viele fragen zur aufführung wir machen
das immer als doppelschlag beginnen
wollen wir mit janine wissler und dann
direkt an die svkler weitere
entschuldigung frau wissler wir fangen
mit ihnen an eine minute die uhr läuft
was wollen sie tun um die
digitalisierung voranzubringen da
brauchen wir dringend höhere
investitionen damit wir schnell das
internet auch im ländlichen raum und
überall flächen decken haben was wollen
sie in zukunft für kinder tun wir
brauchen dringend eine
kindergrundsicherung weil drei millionen
kinder in diesem land in armut leben und
wir brauchen ein bildungssystem wo
bildungschancen nicht abhängig sind von
der sozialen herkunft grenzt sich die
linke genug von linksextremen ab ja wir
lehnen jede form von gewalt ab wie
wollen sie unsere grenzen sichern damit
keine unberechtigten asylsuchenden und
migranten nach deutschland kommen wir
sind der meinung dass man menschen in
not helfen muss und fluchtursachen
beseitigen muss und es gibt 250 städte
in diesem land wie gesagt haben
wesentliche hafen wir haben platz also
menschen in not helfen wie stehen sie zu
der idee eines gemeinsamen europäischen
militärs anstatt 27 unabhängigen wir
sind der meinung wir brauchen ein europa
der abrüstung und der zivilen
konfliktlösung und nicht weiteres
militär warum hat deutschland viel
niedrigere renten als ostösterreich
kurze antwort weil wir eine rentenkasse
haben in denen nicht alle gleichmäßig
einbezahlen nicht alle einkommen
herangezogen werden abgeordnete zum
beispiel auch nicht und das würden wir
gerne ändern dankeschön soweit damit
sind wir bei ihnen frau weiter auch hier
eine minute zeit die uhr läuft jetzt
was wollen sie gegen den
pflegekräftemangel tun noch mal bitte
pflegekräftemangel tun wir müssen die
pflegekräfte deutlich besser bezahlen
die bezahlung ist deutlich unter dem
durchschnitt deswegen haben wir ein für
hege mangel und man muss menschen die so
eine wertvolle aufgabe wahrnehmen muss
man auch vernünftig bezahlen dann hat
man auch keinen pflegenotstand
wie stellen sie in zukunft sicher dass
erwerbstätige eltern ein kita-platz
zugesagt wird
in dem genügend kitaplätze zur verfügung
gestellt werden wie wollen sie
effektiven klimaschutz gestalten das
fängt international an den sonderweg
allein zu gehen in deutschland ist
völlig falsch wenn man an den
menschengemachten klimawandel glaubt
machen wir nur nicht mal zwei prozent
des co2 ausstoßes weltweit aus also es
ist eine internationale aufgabe sollte
man daran festhalten wie möchten sie
qualifizierte einwanderer besser
unterstützen indem man unser
steuersystem reformiert und den standort
deutschland wieder attraktiv macht und
das ist er nicht vielen dank so weit in
meine frau wissler und frau weiter wir
sind damit den ersten thema durch und
kommen zum thema umwelt und klima das
natürlich für viele das sehen wir immer
auch im politbarometer wenn wir fragen
was sind für sie dann so die wichtigsten
thema ein überragend wichtiges thema ist
und dazu kommen wir jetzt und haben auch
dazu zunächst mal ein paar fakten
zusammengetragen in einem einspielfilm
[Musik]
nicht erst seit der flutkatastrophe im
juli ist klar der klimaschutz ist die
zentrale herausforderung unserer zeit
und zum ersten mal auch für eine
mehrheit der bürgerinnen und bürger
wahlentscheidend immerhin 43 prozent
geben an umwelt und klima seien für sie
das wichtigste thema dieser wahl doch
auch wenn es inzwischen sogar im gesetz
steht klimaneutralität bis 2045 über den
weg dorthin wird gestritten über das
datum für den kohleausstieg eine
mögliche solarpflicht für neubauten über
diesel fahrverbote tempolimit ein verbot
von kurzstreckenflügen oder die
abstandsflächen von windrädern und
während sich die grünen als verbots
partei verspotten lassen müssen
vermeiden union und spd bei vielen
themen klare festlegungen beim co2 preis
zum beispiel bleiben beide parteien
schwammig aber die zeit läuft ab die
erderwärmung vollzieht sich schneller
und folgen schwerer als bislang
angenommen so der neueste bericht des
weltklimarats
doch die kann der wandel beim
klimawandel gelingen
[Musik]
eine aktuelle studie hat die kinder die
klima programme der parteien untersucht
herr kubicki die fdp landete für sie
unerfreulicher weise auf dem letzten
platz die begründung die zeit drängt so
sehr dass marktmechanismen alleine das
nicht lösen können springt ihr programm
dazu kurz nein es gibt eine reihe von
studien aus welche interessenlage über
die erstellt worden sind ich weiß nur
dass eine freude der sender von ihnen
mit seinem
wissenschaftsredaktion festgestellt hat
die fdp habe das ambitionierteste
klimaschutzprogramm sie haben es nur
nicht zugetraut dass wir es durch setzen
damit sie deshalb von 1 auf 5
runtergesetzt lassen wir das mal wir
müssen wissen dass wir unser mengen ziel
nur erreichen können wenn wir einen
engen budget einführen und die
überlegung der freien demokraten ist
dass darunter ein emissionshandel
stattfinden kann das heißt dass man sich
verschmutzungsrechte kaufen kann das
kann den preis auch über 70 oder 100
euro hinauf treiben es löst jedenfalls
sehr schnell sehr viele
investitionsbereitschaft in den
unternehmen aus und die kreativität der
technischen fortschritte warum ist das
wichtig funktioniert übrigens im
energiemarkt europaweit mittlerweile die
chinesen interessieren sich dafür warum
ist das wichtig wir haben bei den
pariser klimaschutzabkommen fünf staaten
erlaubt bis 2060 mehr co2 emittieren als
deutschland und europa insgesamt
überhaupt einsparen können weil sonst
die chinesen die in der die indonesia
die brasilien nicht unterschrieben
hätten warum sie wollen dass ihre
bevölkerung auch am wohlstand teilnimmt
also muss es unsere aufgabe sein als
industrienationen techniken zu
entwickeln die es möglich machen
wohlstand und klimaschutz 100 zu
verbinden nur dann können wir auf dem
größten der mit ihren dem markt nehme
ich den beiden chinesen auch was
erreichen die linke frau vista die
strebt klimaneutralität bis 2035 jahren
habe ich das richtig gelesen im programm
ja das ist sogar noch ehrgeiziger als
bei den grünen das geht aber natürlich
nicht ohne radikale einschnitte müssen
sie den leuten ja irgendwie schon auch
sagen wo es wehtut wird die radikalen
einschnitte werden wir haben wir den
klimawandel nicht aufhalten also teurer
als klimaschutz ist kein klimaschutz und
die folgen des klimawandels das sehen
wir jetzt schon also der klimawandel tag
ein fernes horrorszenario mehr sondern
wir leben waldbrände wir leben dürren
wir leben überschwemmungen und deswegen
muss ganz klar sein wenn wir jetzt nicht
entschieden handeln dann werden wir sehr
heftige einschnitte haben und wir sagen
klimaneutralität 20 35 jahre das ist
ambitioniert aber auch nur deshalb weil
in den letzten jahren viel zu wenig
passiert ist weil wir viel zu viel zeit
verloren haben wir müssen durchsetzen um
die klimaschutzziele zu erreichen und
deswegen sagen wir raus aus der kohle
und zwar schnell bis 2030 wir sagen wir
müssen der verkehrswende hin gelegen das
heißt deutschland zum bahn land zu
machen strecken zu reaktivieren den öpnv
ausbauen
tempolimit
ich daher gerade das wir strecken
reaktivieren können herr kubicki das
geht zum beispiel deutlich schneller als
die neu zu bauen sind sehr viele
strecken stillgelegt worden im letzten
jahr wir müssen aufhören wälder zu roden
weil wälder ganz wichtige co2 senken
sind das heißt nicht weiter wälder roden
für autobahnausbau für kohleabbau für
kiesabbau und das sind wichtige
maßnahmen auf dem weg zur erreichung der
klimaziele und natürlich müssen wir auch
die industrie umbauen und wir müssen die
arbeitsplätze in der industrie
nachhaltig sichern und wir dürfen nicht
dafür nicht zulassen dass die menschen
die ohnehin wenig haben die kosten für
den klimaschutz bezahlen sondern wir
brauchen einen sozialen und ökologischen
umbau und dafür stehen wir der strom der
zukunft muss sicherlich blume grüner
strom sein um das klima zu schützen aber
wo sollte er herkommen wenn es weder mit
den ausbau der erneuerbaren so recht
klappt noch mit stromtrassen na ja wir
hatten in den letzten vier jahren in
deutschland einen gewaltigen buhs für
erneuerbare energien ich glaube eine
stromerzeugung der anteile um 14
prozentpunkte zugenommen nähert sich
langsam der 50 prozent marke das ist
schon ganz wichtig zum klimaschutz
generell wir haben hier auch parteien
der extreme auch neben ihr frau seidel
das ist eine partei die alles leugnet
die korona leugnet wie den klimawandel
leugnet stellt sich damit natürlich
völlig außerhalb selbstverständlich
verwaltet stellen sie sich völlig
außerhalb des demokratischen diskurses
diskreditieren sich auch moralisch aber
für uns ist entscheidend dass partei der
mitte klimaschutz mit vernunft zu machen
das heißt erstens deutschland natürlich
dekarbonisierung das heißt aus den
fossilen aussteigen aber eben nicht die
industrialisieren wir wollen
klimaneutrales energie land werden
deutschland mit ambitionierten
klimaschutzzielen versehen vorangehen
aber auch für ausgleich sorgen nicht den
ländlichen raum abhängen deswegen
zentrale position von uns die
pendlerpauschale zu erhöhen wir wollen
die menschen nicht mobilität verbieten
und am ende ist für uns entscheidend die
politische grundhaltung dabei
klimaschutz muss mit anreizen
funktionieren der darf auch spaß machen
die menschen dabei unterstützen aber
nicht versuchen sie umzuerziehen mit
verboten wie das von linker seite immer
gerne getan wird tempolimit ist ja
gerade schon genannt wurden viele andere
dinge da setzen wir lieber auf
innovationen wir glauben das ist der
richtige wir als redaktion haben uns
ihre wahlprogramme natürlich genau
angeguckt auch was das thema
wirtschaftlichkeit zum beispiel betrifft
aber wir sehen natürlich auch dass es
menschen gibt die noch mehr darüber
wissen als wir deshalb haben wir uns
unterstützung geholt hat noch nicht im
wahlprogramm checks haben wir marcel
forscher vom
wirtschaftsforschungsinstitut diw
gebeten die einzelnen programme der
parteien auf schwachstellen und
widersprüche abzuklopfen erwarten sie
also nicht so viel beifall in diesen
einspielfilmen und die erste analyse
kommt zur afd
[Musik]
der klimaschutz ist vielleicht das
dringendste problem dass wir heute in
deutschland haben die fdj dass der
klimawandel menschengemacht ist und
bietet daher keine lösung an wie der
klimawandel gestoppt werden kann
die ard stellt
politik zum klimaschutz und
wirtschaftspolitik in einem gegensatz
aber genau das gegenteil ist der fall
gute klimaschutzpolitik ist gute
wirtschaftspolitik weil sie hilft
arbeitsplätze zu sichern und das klima
zu schützen und wenn das nicht gelingt
in den kommenden jahren werden viele
viele arbeitsplätze in deutschland
verloren gehen und deutschland wird viel
seines wirtschaftlichen wohlstands
einbüßen
[Musik]
der vorwurf an sie frau seidel und die
afg sie gefährden jede menge jobs weil
sie das thema klimaschutz politik nicht
wirklich ernst nehmen was sagen sie dazu
also erstmal gilt das gegenteil dadurch
dass wir eine vernünftige
klimaschutzpolitik und umweltschutz
politik fordern wollen wir gerade unsere
energie wirtschaft als auch unsere
automobilbranche schützen und
arbeitsplätze bewahren wir sagen aber
auch hier ganz klar dass deutschland
diesen sonderweg unbedingt beenden muss
weil er zur energie unsicherheit führt
wir bezahlen bereits jetzt die höchsten
strompreise wir bezahlen die höchsten
energiepreise und wir bezahlen die
höchsten spritpreise und darum sagen wie
auch ganz klar
abschaffung der co2 steuer abschaffung
des eeg es das ist nicht nur mit
zusatzkosten von einer kugel eis zu
bemessen sondern seit 2004 sind die
eeg-kosten um das zehnfache angestiegen
haushalte werden
unmögliche belastet und das ist auch
nicht mehr tragbar und das problem ist
und das hat hier bisher noch niemand
beantwortet wo soll denn eigentlich der
zusätzliche strom auch für die ganze e
mobilität auch herkommen wir würden hier
die automobilindustrie ab das ifo
institut das ist jetzt nicht so
wie herr wie
herr fritzsche ist da natürlich keiner
größer weil das ifo-institut hat er hier
ganz ganz klar bemessen dass indirekt
und direkt
215.000 arbeitsplätze am
verbrennungsmotor hängen und die
gefährdet sind und da habe ich noch
überhaupt gar keine antwort erfahren wie
man das überhaupt weg puffern möchte die
e-mobilität ist deutlich unter komplex
zu verbrennungsmotoren und auch hier zu
sagen das ist alles gar kein problem wir
steuern dieses land in energie und
sicherheit ein ohne zu beantworten wo
eigentlich die zusätzliche energie und
der strom herkommen soll für die
e-mobilität das wird alles nicht
beantwortet ich muss ihnen ganz ehrlich
sagen ich halte diese diskussion für so
unglaublich unseriösen unprofessionell
dass man sich wirklich nur noch die
haare raufen kann denn wie soll denn
eine co2 arme zukunft aussehen ohne
forschung und entwicklungsleistungen
beispielsweise in atomkraft die
niederlande bauern zehn atomkraftwerke
für eine co2 arme zukunft kein anderes
industrieland kommt darauf aus atomkraft
als auch kohle verstromung gleichzeitig
auszusteigen ohne eine lösung parat zu
haben und noch eins für den grünstrom wo
sie gerade gesagt haben herr blume das
grüner strom so unglaublich viel spaß
macht die haushalte die mir zugehört
haben werden sich bei ihnen bedanken um
den energiebedarf zu decken
sind
350.000 windkraftwerke erforderlich die
im übrigen ein viertel der fläche
deutschlands einnehmen und das muss doch
einfach mal mit dazu gesagt werden und
wenn dann der wind nicht bläst dann
steht dann steht hier sowieso alle still
und das steht den leuten nicht sagen es
wird nicht funktionieren dass in dieses
mal frau wissen gerne wieder streut
himmel das ist
ja ich meine wir haben ja jetzt eben
wieder den unsinn gehört vom angeblich
nicht menschengemachten klimawandel und
das ist natürlich alles sehr fakten frei
was wir sagen und sie stellen hier
fragen und hinterfragen dinge die
wissenschaftlich längst erwiesen sind
klar ist doch wir müssen den umbau den
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien den
müssen wir stemmen das ist unbedingt
notwendig also jetzt noch ein revival
der atomkraft zu fordern ist doch
vollkommen absurd wir können nicht
weiter kohle verfeuern sondern den
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien und da
wären jedoch schon längst viel weiter
während das nicht auch diese
bundesregierung gewesen wäre die
wirklich beim ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien gebremst hätte und das ist
dringend notwendig und natürlich müssen
wir daran arbeiten dass die industrie
auch effizienter arbeitet dass es dort
einsparungen gibt unbedingt und dazu
brauchen wir politische flankierung 'nen
und klar ist aber wir haben keine zeit
wir müssen jetzt handeln damit unsere
kinder und kindeskinder noch eine
lebenswerte zukunft auf diesem planeten
haben weil wenn die nächste
bundesregierung ist nicht macht wenn
jetzt noch mal vier jahre vergehen dann
wird es nicht möglich sein die
klimaschutzziele haben freudig allen
vieren hier versprochen dass sie
nochmals zu wort kommen im kreuzverhör
nämlich auch herr kubicki und auch herr
blume und an der stelle sind wir jetzt
die gleichen spielregeln für sie herr
blume kann gerne beginnen es ist eine
minute die zeit läuft runter fragen von
zuschauerinnen und zuschauern möglichst
kurz und knackig beantworten die zeit
läuft jetzt
warum müssen beamte nicht ins
rentensystem einbezahlen unser
rentensystem in deutschland steht auf
verschiedenen säulen auf der
gesetzlichen rente der privaten der
betrieblichen und es gibt ein sonders
system für staatsdiener das hat das eine
historische berechtigung muss der
bundestag so groß sein es war leider
nicht möglich über alle parteien hinweg
zu einer wahlrechtsreform zu kommen das
ist sicherlich eine aufgabe mit der sich
auch der künftige bundestag beschäftigen
muss wie wollen sie den strukturellen
rassismus bekämpfen
das ist das bewusstsein erforderlich in
allen teilen der gesellschaft oder
müssen wir vor allem denen das handwerk
legen die der parlamentarische arm von
rassismus von hass und hetze sind
insbesondere der fdp darf in künftigen
parlamenten keinen platz haben das ist
der demokratische weg ich bin soldat
schreibt jemand was stellen sie sich in
zukunft vor für die auftragslage der
bundeswehr ich wünsche mir dass wir eine
bundeswehr haben die in der lage ist die
soldatinnen und soldaten diejenigen die
unser land kämpfen zu schützen dazu muss
die ausrüstung verbessert werden wir
müssen mehr investieren und wir müssen
international auch unsere
verpflichtungen erfüllen danke für die
kurzen klaren antworten und damit sind
wir bei ihnen herr kubicki auch da die
gleichen spielregeln eine minute zeit
läuft runter und die uhr läuft jetzt
warum fehlen seit mehr als 30 jahren in
allen bundesländern lehrer
sondern ist ja sehr gute frage weil die
schüler bedarfsberechnung immer nur
aufgesetzt hat auf den aktuellen
geburten und nicht fortgeschrieben
worden ist wir wissen dass die
lehrerausbildung mehrere jahre dauert
deshalb müssten wir eigentlich auch ein
überhang karma lehrern vor allem über
den dingen die krank sind oder aus
sonstigen gründen aus zeigen 110 prozent
lehrerversorgung wäre wichtig wie würden
sie junger erwachsener mehr in die
politik einbeziehen durch werbung durch
bessere sendung dieser art politik kann
ja auch spaß machen man kann sie
streiten dass das entscheidende und man
muss einen lösungsweg gemeinsam findet
ihr die gesellschaft zusammenführen da
möchte jemand wissen von ihnen herr
kubicki
sie sich selbst wählen das ist eine sehr
gute frage selbstverständlich werde ich
mir die wehen würde wer sonst wie soll
die aktien rente konkret gestaltet
werden wir wollen dass zwei
prozentpunkte der bisher in
sozialabgaben in einen staatlichen fonds
eingezahlt werden der privat gemanagt
wird ähnlich wie das norwegen und
schweden machen mit hohen renditen die
dann das rentensystem stabilisieren
können warum haben fast alle parteien
angst verfolgt befragen kurze antwort
wir haben davor keine angst wir sind
sogar die volksbefragung nicht auf
bundesebene weil es dazu führt dass
populisten aller regel dann die oberhand
gewinnen das können wir in der schweiz
invite danke in allen weiter geht es
jetzt mit unserem zweiten wahlprogramm
im check von marcel fritsche vom diw
diesmal die csu
in demografische alterung setzt das
deutsche rentensystem massiv unter druck
das heißt vor allem dass die jungen
menschen immer mehr in der form von
steuern und beiträgen zahlen müssen um
die älteren menschen und ihre rente zu
finanzieren die csu verspricht den
menschen eine sichere rente und will das
noch ausbauen beispielsweise über die
mütter rente das bedeutet dass die junge
generation immer stärker belastet wird
dass also keine rede mehr von
generationengerechtigkeit sein kann und
zweitens dass schon heute die
steuerzahler ein viertel des
bundeshaushaltes als zuschuss an die
gesetzliche rente liefern das wird sich
in den kommenden 20 jahren verdoppeln
wenn keine veränderung im rentensystem
stattfindet
[Musik]
da ist der herr forscher nicht ganz
alleine herr blume auch ihre schwester
pippa die große schwester cdu hält eine
erhöhung der mütter rente für nicht
finanzierbar
warum beharren sie darauf weil es eine
gerechtigkeitsfrage ist für millionen
von müttern in unserem land die kinder
geschenkt haben und vor der frage stehen
wenn sie das vor 1992 getan haben dass
sie anders behandelt werden dass sie
weniger rentenpunkte bekommen das ist
einfach eine frage von fairness und wir
würden diese fairness lücke gerne
schließen da fehlt noch ein letzter
halber punkt und wir finden dass das
millionen von müttern in deutschland
verdient haben wir sind jetzt sozusagen
reingerutscht mit diesem filme und ihrer
replik in den dritten themenblock
wirtschaft und soziales und auch dazu
wollen wir uns zunächst mal ein
einspielfilm angucken mit ein paar
fakten
[Musik]
deutschlands wirtschaft wächst wieder
nachdem die korona krise der konjunktur
eine dicke delle beschert hatte haben
viele branchen ihr vorkrisenniveau
wieder erreicht sorgen aber machen den
ökonomen nicht nur mögliche
virusvarianten sondern auch der
materialmangel infolge der pandemie noch
immer sind lieferketten gestört die
rohstoffpreise extrem hoch und auch die
soziale ungleichheit wurde durch die
pandemie besonders sichtbar mehr denn je
gilt wer arm ist in deutschland bleibt
das meist auch wer eltern hat die kein
abitur haben macht selbst deutlich
seltener ab während es von 100
akademiker eltern 74 kinder an die uni
schaffen gelingt das nur 21 kindern von
nicht akademikern
weiter ungelöst auch das thema rente die
beitragssätze steigen die erträge sinken
und einige ökonomen fordern bereits
einen renteneintritt mit 70 haben wir
unseren wohlstand also längst verspielt
die linke frau wissler fordert vieles
eine vier-tage-woche 30 stunden
arbeitszeit ein mindestlohn von 13 euro
das klingt alles wunderbar und wer
bezahlt hast ja ein mindestlohn von
was war nun hat die reichen die von
kubicki vielleicht könnten sie auch wenn
wir dauernd dazwischen zu blubbern
der 13 euro gewährte - nun ja wir sind
der meinung darunter sollte niemand
arbeiten müssen arbeit muss von arbeit
muss man leben können und davon müssen
die menschen ihrer miete bezahlen und
dafür müssen menschen auch irgendwann im
alter von ihrer rente auskommen und man
darf jetzt auch nicht vergessen ich
wohne auch in dieser krise sind ja nicht
alle unternehmen ärmer geworden so ist
es ja nicht gibt der unternehmen die
sehr gut verdient haben in dieser krise
also ob das amazon ist oder so ein paar
masken hersteller mit hilfe von
unionsabgeordneten
also es sind nicht alle ärmer geworden
sondern der reichtum ist noch
ungerechter verteilt durch diese krise
und deswegen sagen wir wir wollen nicht
zulassen dass die schere zwischen arm
und reich immer weiter auseinandergeht
und es kann doch nicht sein dass die
alleinerziehende verkäuferin ihr kind
beim kindergeburtstag krank meldet weil
sich das geburtstagsgeschenk nicht
leisten kann und sich schämt das
zuzugeben nein wir brauchen gute löhne
und das heißt ein höherer gesetzlicher
mindestlohn das heißt aber vor allem
auch dass tarifverträge gelten müssen
und das heißt dass die befristete
beschäftigung zurückgedrängt werden
mussten sie immer mehr beschäftigte
arbeiten in befristeten verträgen zu
werkverträgen in der leiharbeit das
wollen wir abschaffen das wollen wir
zurückdrängen also zumindest die
sachgrundlose befristung damit menschen
möglichst sichere arbeit haben und auch
ihr leben planen können und ich meine
wir leben in einer der reichsten
volkswirtschaften dieser welt und dieser
reichtum wird er arbeitet von den
beschäftigten alltäglich ob er auf dem
bau oder in
anderen bereichen
und diese menschen leiden oder in der
industrie die lacht die halten den laden
am laufen und deswegen müssten sie auch
vernünftig bezahlt werden und gerade in
der krise haben wir doch gesehen die
systemrelevanten das sind die
busfahrerinnen und busfahrer das den die
menschen in den kitas arbeiten und diese
menschen müssen endlich angemessen
entlohnt werden und deswegen wollen wir
für mehr soziale gerechtigkeit und einen
sozialen ausgleich wir haben in dieser
runde auch schon das wort
vermögenssteuer gehört herr kubicki ich
weiß die fdp herzlich so gerne aber sie
können ja gleich begründen warum denn
die hälfte der deutschen hat fast kein
einkommen und die reichsten 10 17
prozent besitzen zwei drittel ist es da
nicht in der tat an der zeit sich über
sowas zu überlegen wie eine
vermögenssteuer natürlich
vermögenssteuer ist er zu recht
ausgesetzt worden weil das
bundesverfassungsgericht gesagt hat
vermögenssteuer plus einkommensteuer da
50 prozent nicht überschreiten das wäre
bei einigen tatsächlich der fall gewesen
vor allem muss man wissen die
vermögenssteuer ist eine substanz
steuern sie haben besteuern die substanz
ohne dass sie sagen können da besteht
liquidität das ist ja kein einkommen wir
haben das war ein beispiel die zu machen
wenn sie aktien von wirecard gehabt
haben zu einem bestimmten zeitpunkt
waren sie richtig vermögend und drei
tage später hatte wirecard insolvenz
gegangen ist waren sie nicht mehr
vermögen zahlen sie jetzt also auch für
stifter vermögenssteuer sind sie pleite
für den rest ihres lebens ohne dass ich
tatsächlich auf substanz sein sie können
doch nicht auf dem grundstück ein
quadratmeter boden rausschneiden und das
dem finanzamt zur verfügung stellen
werden sie risiko hatte auch die aktien
rente nebenbei bemerkt aber die wird
laserpunkt interessanter
interessanterweise wird die aktien breit
gestreut ist ein staatsfonds
ein staatsfonds und sollte privat
gemanagt werde noch einmal wir können
doch auch aus dem ausland lernen die
norweger machen das seit jahrzehnten
erfolgreich vor die schwedin auch warum
lernen wir nicht mehr von anderen dass
man der durchbrüche beteiligung am
wachstum des kapitalmarktes auch
tatsächlich was für die rente tun kann
er das nicht nur im umlageverfahren auf
die beschäftigten abgewälzt also
vermögens und erbschaftssteuer sind ein
sich die für eine funktionierende
wirtschaft herr blume vermögenssteuer
gift für funktionierende wirtschaft sagt
herr kubicki oder ist es notwendig in
einer lage wie jetzt nach der korona
panik also jeder der an der
substanzbesteuerung in der schrauber der
substanzbesteuerung in deutschland
drehen möchte erbschaftssteuer
vermögenssteuer vermögensabgabe man muss
sich ja die programme von grünen von spd
und linken nur übereinander legen das
ist alles gift für den standort
deutschland ist es gift für den zarten
aufschwung und wir reden nicht über
superreiche frau wissler sondern wir
reden über selbständige wir reden über
mittelständler wir reden über handwerker
wir reden über landwirte ich treffe in
diesen tagen als viele landwirte die
fragen sich wenn sie ihr wahlprogramm
studieren wo führten so ein linksbündnis
eigentlich hin sie haben sorge um ihren
hof der hof erwirtschaftet erträge
sollen die dann das nebengebäude dann
verkaufen um ihren hof am laufen halten
zu können es zeigt ist es abenteuerlich
und wenn sie ehrlich wären würden sie
sagen das was ich hier präsentieren ist
eine riesige umverteilungsmaschinerie
und sie trauen sich nicht so deutlich
sagen aber in anderen foren schaffen sie
es ja dann auch deutlich korrigiert sie
träumen die träumen jeden tag vom
demokratischen sozialismus und mit den
corona folgen und so weiter unter diesen
mantel versuchen sie diesem ziel näher
zu kommen enteignungen volles programm
alles bei ihnen sie dem sich ja gar
keine mühe so zu tun als wenn sie das
nicht wollen sie sagen ja
selbstverständlich
wohnungsbaugesellschaften für
gemeinschaft und so dinge abenteuerlich
gift für den standort deutschland sie
haben das stichwort erbschaftssteuer
genannt das würde ich frau weiter gerne
mal weiter fragen denn die afg will
erbschafts und grundsteuer wenn ich es
richtig gelesen habe abschaffen aber das
begünstigt doch auch die reicheren und
belastet menschen mit geringen abkommen
ist das nicht sozial ungerecht dass
das ist nicht ganz richtig es ist eine
noch mal besteuerung aus schon einmal
einkommens besteuert vermögen so es hat
ja auch gerade herr kubicki völlig
richtig ausgeführt und wir sind nicht
nur für die abschaffung jeglicher
substanz steuern also erbschafts und
vermögenssteuer und
der grundsteuer sondern eben auch für
das familiensplitting modell in der
einkommensteuer familien müssen deutlich
mehr entlastet werden weil mittlere
einkommen in europa am höchsten in
deutschland belastet sind und
dementsprechend schlagen wir ein
familiensplitting modell vor das ist
nämlich der einkommensteuersatz
proportional zu der kinderzahl leben
singt und das ist vor allen dingen eine
entlastung für die familien für die
kleineren und mittleren einkommen und
das kriegen sie nicht über eine
vermögenssteuer oder sonstige
umverteilung gelöst denn das was sie
umverteilen das ist eben nun mal in der
ökonomie so das was wir umverteilen das
muss verdient werden und wenn die
abgaben die staatlichen abgaben einfach
zu hoch sind dann setzt der staat
fehlanreize auf den faktor arbeit als
auch die arbeitende bevölkerung die sich
dann irgendwann mal überlegt die steuern
und abgaben sind mir hier in deutschland
viel zu hoch ich arbeite im ausland und
genau das problem haben wir seit über 20
jahren
einen brain drain von deutschen also
eine abwanderung von qualifizierten
arbeitskräften deutschen arbeitskräften
ins ausland vornehmlich in die usa in
die schweiz aber auch mittlerweile nach
asien und diese menschen müssen und wir
müssen wir müssen müssen wir halten und
dementsprechend muss der staat auch
konzepte vorlegen genau die
qualifizierten zu halten und eben auch
den standort deutschland für
qualifizierte ausländische arbeitskräfte
auch attraktiver zu machen daher
gekommen wenn nicht jetzt zum kritischen
blick von marcel fritsche auf das
parteiprogramm der linken
das thema wohnen ist vielleicht mit die
wichtigste soziale frage unserer zeit
die linke will einen mieten deckel
bundesweit verankern und auch
enteignungen damit der staat wohnungen
von privaten wegnehmen kann das wird das
wohnungsproblem in deutschland nicht
lösen sondern verschärfen denn wir sehen
mit der erfahrung in berlin dass der
mieten decke das angebot von wohnungen
reduziert es schwieriger macht für
menschen eine wohnung zu finden und die
preise eher in die höhe treibt also
weder mieten deckel noch in eignungen
sind eine lösung sondern nur eine kluge
wohnungsbaupolitik bauen bauen bauen
da hat er doch irgendwie rechte hetzer
wenn man keine neuen wohnungen baut gibt
es keine neuen wohnraum oder nein er hat
er so nicht recht also ich glaube auch
dass wir bauen müssen und schlagen wir
auch vor aber bauen bauen bauen kann ich
allein die antwort sein erstens wollen
wir nicht die letzte fläche versiegeln
ist auch umweltpolitisch nicht so klug
und zweitens müssen wir doch was dagegen
tun dass bezahlbarer wohnraum vernichtet
wird und die wohnungen die sich die
menschen jetzt in berlin in münchen
frankfurt in den innenstädten nicht mehr
leisten können die wohnungen gibt es ja
noch die sind halt jetzt nur unbezahlbar
und deswegen müssen wir dringend etwas
tun dass die mieten in den innenstädten
und auch darüber hinaus explodieren
deswegen schlagen wir vor einen
bundesweiten mieten deckel um die
mieterinnen und mieter zu schützen ja
und wir sind der meinung wohnungen sind
ein zuhause für menschen die sind kein
anlage und renditeobjekt ein konzern wie
nokia die haben im letzten jahr eine
milliarde euro an die aktionäre
ausgeschüttet ja dieses geld stammt
neben auch aus den taschen der
mieterinnen und mieter und das in corona
ja wo viele wirklich sich verschulden
mussten um überhaupt ihre miete noch
zahlen zu können und deswegen sind wir
der meinung wohnen ist so wichtig und es
dem markt zu überlassen wir brauchen
öffentliche wohnungsgesellschaften
landeseigenen wohnungsgesellschaften die
in diesem land auch hohe tradition haben
wir haben ja auch sehr viele
sozialwohnungen gehabt die sind nur
immer weiter wir sehen eine zahl
gesunken jeden tag gehen 72
sozialwohnungen verloren in diesem land
obwohl es so einen bedarf an bezahlbarem
wohnraum gibt und deswegen ist unsere
position ganz klar wir sind die partei
der mieterinnen und mieter und wir
wollen den mieten deckel durchsetzen
bundesweit und wir wollen dafür sorgen
dass wohnen für alle bezahlbar ist und
die einkommensschwächere mieter oder
selbst geringverdiener nicht verdrängt
werden aus denen ich würde jetzt gerne
herrn blume die chance geben zu erwidern
na ja ich würde sagen der frage stehen
wir auf seite der experten wenn das ist
ja völlig richtig wohnungen nur um zu
verteilen damit es überhaupt nichts
gewonnen und bei aller liebe frau
wissler der mieten deckel in berlin
nicht nur das er verfassungsrechtlich
grandios gescheitert ist in berlin ist
der wohnungsmarkt das bauen von
wohnungen praktisch zum erliegen
gekommen
das schlechteste jahr überhaupt während
bundesweit im jahr 2020 so viele
wohnungen gebaut wurden wie in den
letzten 20 jahren nicht deswegen ist der
weg richtig die mieten kann ich dann
stabil haben wenn ich die große
nachfrage befriedigen deswegen muss ich
möglichst viel bauen wir haben es gerade
auch in unserem sofortprogramm deutlich
gemacht was die richtige weg ist bauen
muss leistbar sein deswegen wenn es
möglichkeiten gibt bei den zusätzlichen
belastungen grunderwerbssteuer runter zu
kommen dann wollen wir den ländern die
möglichkeit geben teil unseres
sofortprogramms und markus söder hat am
parteitag noch anderen punkt genannt der
uns auch wichtig ist der auch die
soziale dimension zeigt das wohngeld ist
etwas was man sich noch mal sehr genau
anschauen muss wir sehen da auch die
notwendigkeit beim wohngeld mehr zu
machen um einkommensschwache familien zu
unterstützen dass sie sich die miete
leisten können herr kubicki sie sonst
nicht leichter haben als die anderen
drei in der runde deshalb hat sich
marcel fritsche auch ihr parteiprogramm
angeguckt mit den kritischen anmerkungen
das hören wir jetzt wie gut sie haben
nicht
deutschland steht heute an einem
wirtschaftspolitischen wendepunkt denn
es muss mit klimaschutz digitale
transformation
und der sozialen polarisierung in
deutschland riesige herausforderung
bewältigen das erfordert massive
zukunftsinvestition die fdp will auf der
einen seite zukunftsinvestitionen
versprechen gleichzeitig vor allem die
spitzenverdiener um 80 milliarden euro
jedes jahr entlasten unter noch die
schuldenbremse einhalten das ist ein
spagat der unmöglich sein wird und die
partei schenkt den menschen keinen
reinen wein ein
[Musik]
im grunde sagt er ja herr kubicki die
fdp verspricht da die quadratur des
kreises stimmt das ich schätze ein
freudscher sehr wir sind beides
volkswirte ich sehe es etwas anders als
er vor allem dafür sozusagen die
rückführung des solidaritätszuschlages
für die oberen zehn prozent der
bevölkerung nicht der steuerpolitik zu
rechnen das ist eine zwangsabgabe
gewesen deren zweck erfüllt ist wir
können das relativ entspannt sehen dass
wir das verfassungsgericht entscheiden
das ist verfassungswidrig ist insofern
haben wir auch nicht versprochen jedes
jahr 80 milliarden zu entlassen sondern
über eine spanne von von vier jahren
eine entsprechende leistung
herbeizuführen gerade bei
familienunternehmen weil deren gewinne
die investitionsmöglichkeiten für die
zukunft beinhalte der frau weiß auch 90
prozent aller investitionen kommen aus
dem privaten bereich nur zehn prozent
aus dem öffentlichen bereich sagt macht
es sinn die privaten zu stärken weil wir
heute schon die mittel die wir im
haushalt zu 30 prozent nicht ausgeben
können weil beispielsweise
planungskapazitäten fehlen weil die
verfahren zu lange dauern kommissar die
abwicklung der strecke münchen berlin 26
jahre gedauert gesagt schaffen innerhalb
von vier fünf jahren keine neuen oder
auch keine richtung eisenbahnstrecken
also privatinvestitionen herbeizuführen
wir haben uns einen leben modell in den
80er jahren hat gerhard stoltenberg
damals finanzminister eine große
steuerreform durchgeführt alle haben
gesagt es gibt eine riesen
staatsverschuldung ist hier da bereits
ein jahr später wegen des wachstums
schuster dadurch ausgelöst worden ist
waren steuereinnahmen vorher höher als
vor der steuerreform was ähnliches
wollen wir entfesseln nach der wahl und
ich glaube wir werden gute argumente
dafür haben und auch die zwischen und
die bevölkerung bekomme ich waren sehr
lange dauern liegt auch daran dass sehr
viele stellen im öffentlichen dienst
abgebaut wurden weil parteien sind wir
immer vom schlanken staat gesprochen
haben das ist einfach an den
genehmigungsbehörden er
selbstverständlich sind
das ist doch nicht nur in berlin so wir
können aus hessen braucht sich beispiele
nennen der öffentliche dienst ist in
teilen auch kaputt gespart wurden und es
ist auch ein grund warum verfahren
wollte alleine alleine eine
umweltverträglichkeitsprüfung dauert
zwei jahre wir haben gesetzliche
regelung geschaffen die sie gar nicht
innerhalb von vier oder fünf jahren
abarbeiten können das ist das problem
deshalb wollen ja auch die grünen sie
übrigens auch in ihrem programm in
bestimmten bereichen eine beschleunigung
der verfahren beispielsweise noch nass
war sagt ja dass partei oder vier jahren
habe ich im übrigen auch gar nicht
gesprochen aber wenn wir nicht langsam
mal anfangen also vielleicht kommen ja
mal anfangen dann haben wir vielleicht
auch hier werden dann fangen keine sorge
die hunde frau würde ich gerne stellen
zum stichwort rente dass es ein paar mal
angeklungen so kann man ja sagen in der
finanziellen lage in der deutschland ist
müsste man ehrlicherweise sagen die
rente muss später kommen vielleicht erst
mit 70 sagen aber andere herr kubicki
fdp man muss auch den weg frei machen
dass leute mit 60 angehen können dass es
sich bei uns zu bedienen ist und frau
wissler sagt mit 65 schon irgendwie alle
bälle in der luft was stimmt naja man
muss ja mal faktisch sagen dass es sehr
viele berufe gibt wo die menschen nicht
bis 67 arbeiten können und auch nicht
bis 65
also schauen wir uns zum beispiel die
pflege an die durchschnittliche
pflegekraft geht mit 60,9 jahren in
rente oder wenn man auf dem bau arbeitet
auf dem handwerk dass die ehe von dem
sie eben gesprochen haben im
handwerksbereich oder in anderen
bereichen in denen menschen körperlich
arbeiten da können die nicht bis 67
arbeiten oftmals nicht bis 65 das heißt
jede woche gehen dann in rente wenn sie
nicht mehr können aber eben zu hohen
abschlägen und deswegen muss ich sagen
dass sie als auch noch eine erhöhung des
renteneintrittsalters zu reden das doch
wirklich ein schlag ins gesicht derer
denen man letztes jahr applaudiert hat
in der korona krise die leute die nicht
ins home office konnten ja und täglich
hardware gearbeitet haben und deswegen
sagen wir wir wollen die rente ab 67
zurücknehmen weil sie ist eine
rentenkürzung und wir wollen die rente
so umgestalten dass sie auch
finanzierbar ist und deswegen müssen wir
nicht auf privatisierung und aktien
rente setzen weil natürlich eine
alleinerziehende verkäuferin kann nicht
privat fürs alter vorsorgen wovon soll
das denn machen es vor wenn sie ihre
miete vielleicht bezahlen kann von jörg
schade es wäre eine gesetzliche rente
die nicht nur vor armut schützt sondern
er ist jeder im alter in würde leben
kann würde gerne noch erfahren wie das
die csu sieht also ich bin der festen
überzeugung renten populismus hilft uns
nicht weiter bei der rente ist eines
ganz entscheiden nämlich verlässlichkeit
rentner ist wertschätzung für
lebensleistung wer ein leben lang
gearbeitet hat der soll und muss davon
im alter auch leben können ich bin ganz
stark dafür dass wir bei dem
vereinbarten renten fahrplan bleiben
deswegen keine debatte anfangen am
renteneintrittsalter zu schrauben aber
gleichzeitig auch der jungen generation
zu signalisieren dass wir an morgen
denken deswegen findet sich im programm
der union beispielsweise die
generationen rente weil wir neben den
existierenden sollen natürlich überlegen
müssen wie wir zusätzliche
stabilisierung schaffen können in der
zukunft auch mit kapitaldeckung ich
glaube am ende macht ein vernünftiger
mix wir müssen auch mehr bei der
privaten vorsorge tun riester ist in
weiten teilen ordentlich gelaufen aber
es hat trotzdem ich so den absolut
durchschlagenden erfolg gehabt das heißt
das rentensystem nicht komplett neu auf
den kopf stellen da gibt es überhaupt
keine veranlassung sondern die menschen
die verlässlichkeit geben die sie
erwarten wir sind am ende dieser sendung
aber nicht ohne dass ich ihnen allen
vieren gerne die gelegenheit geben
möchte in 40 sekunden noch einmal für
sich ihre standpunkte und ihre partei zu
werben ein countdown wird dabei laufen
wie vorhin auch im kreuzverhör sie
wissen also wenn die zeit rum ist bitte
nicht so sehr darüber hauen beginnen wir
doch mal mit ihnen warum sollten die
leute auf den wald läuft weil wir für
steuer und abgaben erleichterung stehen
für die abschaffung für die abschaffung
vollständig des solís des eeg es der co2
besteuerung der absenkung der
einkommenssteuer setzte und für das
familiensplitting modell der mittelstand
muss deutlich mehr entlastet werden wir
stehen für eine geregelte
zuwanderungspolitik wir halten nichts
und beziehen zu felde gegen die illegale
asylpolitik die hier betrieben wird
völlig illegal und verfassungswidrig aus
unserer sicht wir brauchen eine
geregelte kontrollierte zuwanderung und
wir müssen uns dem thema der inneren
sicherheit wird man der mit der
ungeregelten zuwanderung gibt es auch
mehr kriminalität danke dafür wolfgang
kubicki für die fdp hat jetzt das wort
40 sekunden zeit die uhr laufen
wir wollen die wirtschaftliche
leistungsfähigkeit unserer wirtschaft
und wettbewerbsfähigkeit erhalten und
ausbauen weil das die grundlage unseres
wohlstandes ist und vor allen dingen
weil damit die steuern generiert werden
die wir für alle leistungen brauchen die
wir im kopf haben wir wollen dazu
beitragen dass solch eine
mengenbegrenzung der co2 emission die
klimaschutzziele erreicht werden können
darunter ein emissionshandel
implementieren der die preise dann für
co2 emissionen festsetzt wir wollen sehr
viel für die schulen tun wir brauchen
unbedingt wlan an allen schulen
glasfaserausbau und tablets für alle
schülerinnen schüler denn das ist die
zukunft und wir garantieren eine
schnellstmögliche rückkehr zur
grundrechtlichen normalität in dieser
partie nie krise und danach
das war fast eine punktlandung von herrn
kubicki mit dem schlussakkord und damit
sind wir bei in dschenin wissler sie
haben im vorgespräch so ein bisschen
befremdet mit dem format ich bin ganz
gespannt wir haben auch 40 sekunden und
die uhr läuft
schluss mit der politik der verlorenen
zeit wir müssen jetzt handeln und zwar
für soziale gerechtigkeit für
bezahlbaren wohnraum und vor dem
klimaschutz weil das muss jetzt
passieren wir haben keine zeit berg und
die linke ist die partei der die werte
von gerechtigkeit und solidarität nach
vorne stellen soll will und solidarität
das bedeutet autos solidarität und
teilbar ist das heißt dass wir kämpfen
müssen gegen alle formen von rassismus
und menschenfeindlichkeit und dass wir
der wachsenden gefahr von rechts in
diesem land etwas entgegensetzen müssen
damit niemand in diesem land
diskriminiert oder ausgegrenzt wird
sondern wirklich alle gleichberechtigt
überleben können ich sehe mit freude
dass sie alle die 40 sekunden im blut
haben sehr gut und jetzt hat auch markus
blume sein schlussplädoyer ebenfalls 40
sekunden und die zeit läuft
deutschland steht vor einer
fundamentalen richtungsentscheidung bei
dieser richtungsentscheidung am 26
september dem tag der bundestagswahl
geht es um die nächsten jahre um den
kurs den deutschland nimmt wir sind hier
klar positioniert bei der ersten weiche
wir wollen entlasten statt belasten
steuerlich entlasten und keine neuen
belastungen für die bürgerinnen und
bürger wir sind der meinung wir brauchen
neues wachstum statt neue schulden
beispielsweise und wir sind auch der
festen überzeugung das geht am besten
mit anreizen und eben nicht mit boten in
ein lebensbereichen am ende heißt die
große richtungsentscheidung stabilität
oder linksrutsch stabilität für die
stand immer in der geschichte der
republik die union und gerade im blick
auf bayern ist die csu die wahl der
dinge ein schlusswort ist ein
schlusswort weil danach nicht mehr
diskutiert wird das steht alles frei und
die zuschauerinnen und zuschauer können
sich ihr bild machen und haben das
sicher getan vielen dank für die
intensive diskussion in dieser knappen
stunde an sie hier im studio ich glaube
dass sie viel mitnehmen können auch
zuhause für ihre wahlentscheidung hat es
hoffentlich ein stück leichter gemacht
da war ja viel drin strittige ist
nachdenkenswertes und diesen
schlagabtausch haben wir aus
termingründen vor etwa zwei stunden
aufgezeichnet unter live-bedingungen
alle weiteren informationen zur wahl
jederzeit unter zdf heute.de und ab
morgen auch der faktencheck in der zdf-
heute im zdf programm geht es jetzt
weiter mit dem fernsehfilm die jägerin
in einem noch einen schönen abend auf
wiedersehen
tja und hier bei uns im programm geht
weiter mit matthias fornoff der auch bei
uns in diesem format ist denn das es
nicht live sondern aufgezeichnet hat für
uns den vorteil dass matthias jetzt luft
und lust und zeit hat auch mit uns
darüber zu reden wie die sendung aus
seiner sicht gelaufen ist darüber freuen
wir uns dass er gleich dabei ist wir
freuen uns über sie zu hause oder wo
auch immer sie sind schreiben sie uns
ihre fragen und kommentare wie immer in
die kommentarspalten und wenn sie jetzt
youtube nutzen dann bitte einmal die
seite neu laden damit sie auch mit
kommentieren können ansonsten auch wie
gewohnt die eingeblendete und bekannte e
mail adresse mit dabei ist weiterhin
professor andrea römmele die
politikwissenschaftlerin aus mannheim
zugeschaltet hat auch alles mitverfolgt
frau professor wille was ist ihr erster
eindruck
ja ich fand es eine sehr informative
sendung ich fand sie war extrem gut
strukturiert mir kam die fragen die
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer zwischen
rein stellen konnten es hat mir sehr gut
gefallen der faktencheck von dem
kollegen fratzscher der zwischen rhein
geschaltet war hat mir gut gefallen und
ja die kandidaten hatten raum
ihre thesen ihrer programme ihre ideen
vorzustellen und ganz zentral
bürgerinnen und bürger sind informiert
worden und es sind auch die unterschiede
zwischen den einzelnen parteien klar
geworden also erster
erstes so mein erstes empfindet es war
eine gelungene stunde ein gelungenes
format was waren für sie die highlights
gab es momente aussagen die ihnen jetzt
so ganz spontan besonders hängen
geblieben sind
ja also so die reibereien zwischen herrn
kubicki und und frau wissler sind
natürlich so ein bisschen hängen
geblieben weil es ja sonst wenig
gegeneinander auch war es war das
darstellen der eigenen positionen es war
das beantworten von fragen aber es war
jetzt nicht ein duell oder 1 tl also
oder ein quartett wo die einzelnen
protagonisten
gegeneinander gesprochen haben das
einzige was man eben feststellen konnte
oder was sich durch die sendung gezogen
hat waren die reibereien zwischen frau
wissler und herrn kubicki dann blicken
wir darauf noch einmal gesondert denn
auch wenn man weiß dass herr kubicki
einen freund des streitbaren wortes ist
und dass er einer ist der zum entspannen
nachts kriegsfilme zuhause anschaut
selbst wenn man das alles weiß dann hat
man heute noch einmal mit großen augen
zugeguckt und
hingehört wie dieses duell zwischen den
beiden abgelaufen ist zwischen ihm und
frau wissen wir haben ein paar
ausschnitte
sie müssen vielleicht ein bisschen
wirtschaftliches ein dynamischer prozess
und kein statischer verzog sie wollen ja
90 milliarden steuerentlastungen das
steht ja bei ihr ist das ist wohl eher
sparsam noch ist das in irgendeiner form
seriös dass es wirklich
finanzpolitisches motto was jemand
machen und deswegen muss ich mir glaube
ich von ihnen
erinnern nur an die mövenpick steuer und
anderes also fürs eigene klientel also
wenn sich ja nun nicht so viel von
wirtschaft verstehen würden wer die ddr
nicht untergegangen die linke frau
wissler fordert vieles eine
vier-tage-woche 30 stunden arbeitszeit
ein mindestlohn von 13 euro das klingt
alles wunderbar und wer bezahlt das
ja ein mindestlohn von
die reichen
vielleicht könnten sie auch wenn wir
dauernd dazwischen zu blubbern
das war durchaus die highlights auch
hier für uns in der redaktion
matthias bonhof ist jetzt auch war mit
dabei matthias was war dein eindruck hat
sich das überrascht dass die beiden dann
doch so aneinander geraten sind
na ja inhaltlich nicht wirklich die sind
in der tat aneinandergeraten das lager
ein bisschen daran frau wissler hat ja
dann ein bisschen er chauffiert gesagt
blubbern mir dass ich mir nicht immer
dazwischen das in der tat herr kubicki
immer so kleine spitzen gesetzt hat
werden sie redete und das irritiert
natürlich
also das war sozusagen auf der
zwischenmenschlichen ebene schwierig
aber auch inhaltlich liegen die parteien
natürlich meilenweit auseinander
insofern hat mich dieser konflikt nicht
überrascht es gab ja noch einen zwischen
blumen und frau weide das kann auch
mehrfach in der sendung nur sie hat sich
gar nicht so richtig dagegen gewehrt
also er hat sie mehrfach angeschossen
und es kam nichts zurück die sendung
heißt aber auch schlagabtausch und nicht
kuschelbär insofern war ich ganz froh
dass das so ein bisschen gefunkt hat und
wahrscheinlich haben die zuschauerinnen
und zuschauer das auch goutiert dass ein
bisschen emotion und lebendigkeit dabei
war dann ist es natürlich insofern
interessant sich das noch mal ein
bisschen genauer anzugucken weil wenn
denn die spd am wahlabend die
möglichkeit hätte sich koalitionspartner
zu suchen dann könnte sie sich zwischen
diesen beiden entscheiden wir gucken mal
auf die zahlen des politbarometers die
ihr erhoben habt
matthias wenn da war die frage wenn die
spd die wahl hätte zwischen einer
koalition mit den grünen und der fdp
oder mit den grünen und der linken dann
sollte sie sich entscheidend für und
hier sehen wir 55 prozent für grüne und
fdp 29 prozent für grüne und linke das
ist hier auf der einen seite die
präferenz und man wird sehen dass sie
sich oder man kann beobachten ob sie
sich entscheidet für grüne fdp 51
prozent und grüne linke 33 prozent das
heißt aber das ist tatsächlich eine sehr
spannende auch inhaltliche
auseinandersetzung und das frau
professor rummel hat natürlich die
diskussion auch so besonders spannend
gemacht
ja das sehe ich auch so
die linke wurde also frau wissler wurde
ja auch ganz klar danach gefragt wie
ihre position wie die position der
linken zur nato ist zu west bündnissen
ist und er hat sie eine relativ klare
antwort gegeben was natürlich mögliche
koalitionen eine mögliche koalition mit
der linken
schwierig macht wir haben gestern im
trial
gehört dass herr scholz hier die türe
etwas auf lässt aber frau bisher war
hier sehr eindeutig
dann schauen wir uns nochmal die nächste
[Musik]
grafik an die das politbarometer auch
erhoben hat eine von vielen denen die
bewertung von koalitions modellen ist
natürlich auch interessant gewesen da
sehen wir dass ein bündnis aus spd
grünen und fdp schlecht finden 41
prozent und gut 33 cdu csu grüne und fdp
52 gut finden dass 29 prozent spd grüne
und linke würden schlecht finden 56
prozent und 28 würden das gut finden
dass also in dieser konstellation bei
der befragung das am wenigsten
beliebte modell weil wir ja gerade auf
die kleineren in anführungszeichen
parteien heute abend gucken doch mal die
frage an sie frau professor rummel die
frage nach koalitionsaussagen wird man
da auch noch auf zwischentöne hören in
den nächsten zwei wochen bis zur wahl
ja ich meine diese zwischentöne gab es
ja jetzt auch in der vergangenheit und
die wird es auch weiter geben man
spricht dann gerne von einem
wunschpartner einer wunschkoalition
also das ist in einem wahlkampf ganz
normal klar ist aber auch dass jede
partei jetzt um das maximale kämpft und
koalitionsaussagen einfach erst nachdem
oder erste richtungen erst nach dem 26
september
preisgegeben werden ja man hört jetzt
etwas stärker wer der wunschpartner sein
könnte aber jeder lässt es nach ein
seiten hin offen
matthias es sind noch zwei wochen bis
zur wahl wie angespannt hast du die
kandidatinnen und kandidaten heute abend
erlebt vor der sendung nach der sendung
in den gesprächen die ihr geführt habe
naja die wissen natürlich schon jetzt
geht es um alles sind gerade noch zwei
wochen wenn man jetzt einen fehler macht
dann ist das verheerend den kriegt man
nicht mehr eingefangen insofern sind die
schon alle sehr fokussiert und
kontrolliert ich hatte aber vor allem
den eindruck dass hier alle sehr im flow
sind die haben zum teil 34
veranstaltungen am tag in fernsehstudios
auf marktplätzen und so weiter das heißt
die sind da jetzt richtig im tunnel
richtung sechsundzwanzigster september
aber ich habe sie nicht als übermäßig
angespannt erlebt
es gibt ganz viele fragen hier im chat
von denen ich jetzt nur ein paar
vorlesen kann die sich damit
beschäftigen warum zitat so viel hat man
über facebook zum beispiel fragt warum
war denn herr blume da also die frage
warum in dieser runde die csu einen
eigenen vertreter schicken durfte wie
gesagt nur eine kleine auswahl ulrike
odom sind über mail ich halte es für
falsch dass die csu in der heutigen
runde vertreten ist und b punktlos peer
golle über mail auch per e mail fragt
wieso sitzt die csu da erstens nur in
bayern wählbar und zweitens mit der
schwesterpartei cdu einen eigenen
kanzlerkandidaten
wettbewerbsverzerrung drei
ausrufezeichen matthias kannst du das
erklären
ich kann es zunächst mal verstehen dass
man so kritische fragen stellt wir
müssen uns ja dann entscheiden was
wollen wir mit so einer sendung und die
überschrift für uns hieß ganz klar wir
lassen die kleineren im bundestag
vertretenen parteien mit ihren
programmen und inhalten und zielen zu
wort kommen und dazu zählt die csu sie
ist eine eigenständige partei die
haben's ja selbst gesagt die da
geschrieben haben die in bayern antritt
und die cdu eben nicht und wir haben
jetzt wenn man das mal inhaltlich sieht
in den letzten jahren ja deutlich
gesehen dass das mitnichten eine große
harmonie ist zwischen cdu und csu weder
in der frage wer wird kanzlerkandidat
noch in der flüchtlingspolitik also dass
diese partei schon ein eigenes profil
hat und darauf besteht das ist klar aber
trotzdem ich saß noch mal man kann diese
frage stellen wir haben es so
entschieden weil wir es unter der
überschrift kleinere parteien und ihre
ziele gemacht haben und ich fand das
dann in der runde hat sich das auch
gelohnt noch quasi frage in richtung
redaktions entscheidung backstage was
die themen angeht gab es gestern viel
kritik am trainer das große themen wie
zb die außenpolitik europa gar nicht an
wochen wurden wie habt ihr eure themen
zusammenstellung besprochen und was war
euer ansatz für die sendung heute
na ja wir hatten ja zunächst mal
niemanden da der kanzler oder kanzlerin
werden will oder ernsthaft könnte also
so eine richtlinienkompetenz kann ja
absehbarer weise von den vieren heute
niemand reklamieren oder haben das ist
schon mal ein unterschied zum trio und
ich glaube wir haben für uns entschieden
wir hatten 50 minuten mit vier
politikerinnen und politikern mit
einspielfilmen und format ideen die wir
hatten da muss man schon aufpassen dass
man nicht aus dem ruder läuft wir haben
dann drei große themenblöcke gesetzt
nämlich mit corona das einfach jeden
nach wie vor betrifft und jede und uns
weiter beschäftigen beschäftigen wird
absehbarer weise wir haben dann gesagt
das ganz große thema sagen die
allermeisten menschen uns auch im
politbarometer das ist klima- energie-
umwelt- und das dritte war dann von uns
wirtschaft soziales rente all das und
das sind die zentralen themen für eine
bundestagswahl oder für diese
bundestagswahl
wir haben ehrlich gesagt gedacht dass
über dieses netz verhör das kreuzverhör
wo die fragen der zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer hereinkamen dass da auch mal
jemand fragt zur außenpolitik das kam
aber interessanterweise gar nicht also
wir hatten außenpolitik irgendwie schon
drin mit der renten geschichte in
österreich und mit anderen dingen aber
es stimmt das war auch bei uns kein
schwerpunkt das haben wir vorher so
entschieden klar ist afghanistan wichtig
ist aber ein bisschen auch schon
rückblick auf das was deutsche politik
gemacht hat deshalb haben wir gesagt die
drei themen für die wir uns entschieden
haben plus die vielen themen die von den
zuschauerinnen zuschauern kamen das
trägt so eine sendung und überfrachtet
sie auch nicht aber es stimmt wenn man
hat dann man muss sich immer entscheiden
und wir haben an dieser stelle
entschieden dass außenpolitik
wahrscheinlich nicht eines der drei
wichtigsten themen in diesem wahlkampf
ist und deshalb haben wir es nicht
gemacht eine frage noch an dich bevor
wir dann auch mit ihnen wieder
weitermachen frau professor wille wo
habt ihr denn den söder gelassen fragt
hier ein zuschauer das ist auch
aufgefallen dass verschiedene
funktionen dort vertreten waren die
einen haben die parteivorsitzenden
geschickt in dem fall die csu den
generalsekretär war das absicht damit
man nicht einen gegenkandidaten zu hören
lassen quasi erscheinen lässt der nun
mal gestern seinen auftritt hatte oder
wie kannst du die die auswahl der
parteien für ihr personal in eurer runde
erklären
na ja die gute frage also die haben
natürlich viele termine im moment auch
bei der ard heute abend noch mal auch
bei pro sieben sat 1 gab es was und wird
noch mal was geben und bei rtl gab es
was die müssen sich ein bisschen
aufteilen kein einzel mehr keine
einzelne kann die alle wahrnehmen klar
zum teil das drei mal stattfindet
insgesamt kommen natürlich die drei
spitzenkandidaten oder die kandidatin
susanne runde wie wir sie hatten heute
kommen spitzenkandidaten aber eben auch
jemand wie herr kubicki als
stellvertretender parteichef weil
lindner auf einer anderen veranstaltung
ist das finde ich ist kein problem die
keine dieser parteien ist eine one woman
oder one man show über das eigenständige
thema csu haben wir bereits gesprochen
da konnte ja kein spitzenkandidat kommen
weil sie ja bekanntermaßen das nicht
geworden ist insofern war das mit mit
blumen dem generalsekretär völlig okay
besetzt ich fand das ging ganz gut so
frau professor remmele was glauben sie
wie
wahlentscheidend sind solche formate
gestern das duell heute der
schlagabtausch die komprimierte
möglichkeit für kandidatinnen und
kandidaten sich zu präsentieren vor
großem publikum welchen ausschlag gibt
das
als erster muss man sagen dass es
eigentlich ein wunderbares format ist
für menschen die vielleicht nicht ganz
so politik interessiert sind oder
politik interessiert sind aber
vielleicht nicht so viel zeit haben
ständig die nachrichten zu verfolgen ist
es eine komprimierte art und weise auch
im vergleich politikerinnen und
politiker zu hören wofür sie stehen und
wie gesagt dass auch im vergleich dass
man dann direkt die
unterschiede auch sieht das vielleicht
mal vorab also es hat was extrem
informatives es ist sicherlich jetzt
auch ein format vor allem für diejenigen
die noch unentschieden sind
aus der forschung wissen wir dass diese
formate
einen gewissen effekt haben diese aber
nach zwei drei tagen auch wieder ab
und es geht natürlich auch um die frage
bis verstand jetzt heute was ich
übrigens sehr schön fand es stand nicht
im vordergrund wer hat hier gewonnen
oder wer hat hier verloren aber
natürlich ist es so wenn die
spitzenkandidatin und die
spitzenkandidatin miteinander reden was
wir gestern im trial hatten da ist
natürlich die große frage wer hat
gewonnen wer hat verloren das hat eine
gewisse auswirkungen auf die wählerinnen
und wähler aber wie gesagt diese wirkung
verpufft eigentlich nach 23 tagen das
ist der erste punkt und der zweite punkt
so eine richtige wirkung hat einen ein
duell oder 1 tl eigentlich nur dann wenn
wir massive fehler bei den kandidaten
feststellen also wenn jemand wirklich
gar nicht für formt jetzt haben wir es
heute aber auch gestern mit profis zu
tun wo eigentlich mit solchen
ausrutschern nicht zu rechnen ist
dann schauen wir mal darauf wie gut es
den teilnehmenden gelungen ist die
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer zu
überzeugen wir haben mal die schluss
statements zusammen komprimiert die
können wir uns anschauen
wir stehen für eine geregelte
zuwanderungspolitik wir halten nichts
und wir ziehen zu felde gegen die
illegale
asylpolitik die hier betrieben wird
völlig illegal und verfassungswidrig aus
unserer sicht wir brauchen eine
geregelte kontrollierte zuwanderung und
wir müssen uns dem thema der inneren
sicherheit widmen darum geregelten
zuwanderung gibt es auch mehr
kriminalität wir wollen sehr viel für
die schulen tun wir brauchen unbedingt
wlan an allen schulen glasfaserausbau
und tablets für alle schülerinnen
schüler denn das ist die zukunft und wir
garantieren eine schnellstmögliche
rückkehr zur grund brechen normalität in
dieser pandemie krise und danach die
linke ist die partei der die werte von
gerechtigkeit und solidarität nach vorne
stellen soll will und solidarität das
bedeutet autos solidarität und teilbar
ist das heißt dass wir kämpfen müssen
gegen alle formen von rassismus und
menschenfeindlichkeit und dass wir der
wachsenden gefahr von rechts in diesem
land etwas entgegensetzen müssen damit
niemand in diesem land diskriminiert
oder ausgegrenzt wird sondern wirklich
alle gleichberechtigt überleben können
wir wollen entlasten statt belasten
steuerlich entlasten und keine neuen
belastungen für die bürgerinnen und
bürger wir sind der meinung wir brauchen
neues wachstum statt neue schulden
beispielsweise und wir sind auch der
festen überzeugung das geht am besten
mit anreizen und eben nicht mit verboten
in allen lebensbereichen
am ende heißt die große
richtungsentscheidung stabilität oder
linksrutsch stabilität für die stand
immer in der geschichte der republik die
union und gerade im blick auf bayern ist
die csu die wahl der dinge
herr matthias frau professor am inn hat
gerade gesagt es sind alle profis so
eine 40 sekunden zusammenfassungen das
machen die wahrscheinlich einfach so aus
der hüfte trotzdem wirkt das natürlich
sehr gelernt es hat keiner sich
versprochen es hat keiner irgendwie den
faden verloren
ist das für euch journalisten dann vor
ort irgendwie der moment an dem man
denkt ach komm zeig doch bisschen mehr
menschlichkeit oder an der stelle könnte
man irgendwie noch mal ein bisschen mehr
varianz reinbringen gerade dieses
schluss statements sind doch auch noch
mal die möglichkeit so einen kleinen
funken rüberzubringen den man bislang
nicht hatte würdest du dir da ein
bisschen mehr kreativität wünschen
kann man so sehen christina ja die haben
für sich alle vier offenbar entschieden
dass sie das format
schlussplädoyer so verstehen dass sie
nochmal inhalte reinpacken wofür sie und
ihre parteien stehen was ihnen wichtig
ist mit blick auf die bundestagswahl und
die zeit danach das ist ja auch legitim
und ok und die wussten vorher dass wir
so was machen würden haben sich
selbstverständlich was überlegt und die
frau wissler hatte mir im vorgespräch
auch gesagt da müssen wir das wirklich
machen hier so und so ein schlusswort es
wird ja immer wie auswendig gelernt das
stimmt man kann sich auch noch mal
andere formate überlegen ich finde aber
dass die fähre das letztlich ganz gut
gemacht haben und so und das ist ja der
sinn der übung deshalb haben wir heute
ja nicht permanent über koalitionen
gesprochen sondern wir wollten wirklich
dass hier unterschiede in inhalten
sichtbar werden und das hat auch dieses
schlusswort noch mal ganz schön auf den
punkt gebracht fand ich frau professor
am ende wer konnte denn ihrer meinung
nach am besten punkten
bringt ich finde das hat jeder so auf
seine art und weise
ist da ist er okay rübergekommen
ich fand frau beide war erstaunlich und
aggressiv muss ich sagen
aber wir haben diese schluss statements
ja natürlich das in summe sind natürlich
sind es die werbeblöcke der parteien
aber sie fassen auch komprimierte art
und weise noch einmal zusammen wofür
diese partei steht und weil es dann vier
mal 40 sekunden
hintereinander sind habe ich auch noch
mal als als zuschauerin als zuschauer
die unterschiede der parteien noch mal
klar vorne also mir hat diese
schlussrunde eigentlich gut gefallen
matthias hier kommt oft die frage nach
der redezeit kannst du dazu was sagen
wer hat denn am wenigsten
beziehungsweise am meisten gesprochen
na ja ich sag mal so man kann so ein
format und das ist jedenfalls meine
überzeugung und die der redaktion nicht
völlig überfrachten mit regeln also wir
hatten ja schon zwei formate dieser art
nämlich dieses kreuzverhör wo die uhr
eine minute lang runter läuft und nur so
viel zeit ist und die gerade
besprochenen schlussplädoyers jetzt auch
noch die uhr ständig in der hand zu
haben wenn die sich dann mal
untereinander setzen oder
auseinandersetzen find ich keine gute
art dann ist es auch irgendwann kein
schlagabtausch mehr wir haben uns bemüht
das so zu machen dass die rede anteile
ungefähr gleich sind und wenn ich das so
sagen darf ich glaube auch nicht dass
die die in so ner seinem die größten
rede anteile körpern damit die meisten
punkte machen also ich hatte auch den 1
dass alle vier sich fair behandelt
fühlten und darum geht es letztlich und
nicht um 20 sekunden mehr oder weniger
dann schauen wir noch mal wie groß die
zahl der unentschiedenen ist auch da
gibt es ergebnisse von einer umfrage von
der forschungsgruppe wahlen die das
politbarometer veröffentlicht hat und da
sieht man dass die gruppe derer die noch
nicht wissen wen sie wählen wollen sehr
sehr groß ist ich hoffe wir können die
grafik gerade mal zeigen
warten noch ein momentchen da ist sie
genau meine wahlentscheidung ist sicher
sagen 59 prozent 41 prozent sagen nein
also 41 prozent gilt es noch zu gewinnen
und zu überzeugen von sich matthias was
glaubst du erwartet uns in den nächsten
beiden wochen in den letzten heißen
tagen dieses wahlkampfs
ja das ist so viele sind noch 41 prozent
die noch nicht wissen ob sie wählen
gehen und wen das ist in der tat viel zu
diesem zeitpunkt und auch mehr als vor
vier jahren wir sind aber auch in einer
völlig anderen situation es gibt kein
amtsinhaber mehr der wieder antritt es
ist so ein gefühl bei vielen wählerinnen
und wählern auch naja hier geht es jetzt
richtig um was aber in welche richtung
eigentlich ich glaube man sieht auch an
dem großen interesse für das tri l
gestern auch bei den 14 bis 49 jährigen
also eine etwas jüngeren altersgruppe
dass die leute sich informationen jetzt
holen wir reden immer fünf wochen vorher
schon über bundestagswahlen die
allermeisten bürgerinnen und bürger
konzentrieren sich darauf erst dann wenn
die wahl kurz bevor steht nämlich jetzt
und dann holen sie sich informationen
außerdem verwahrt format wie dem trio
oder unserem schlagabtausch und ich
glaube das ist ganz wichtig was erwartet
uns in den nächsten zwei wochen das ist
eine gute frage die kristallkugel habe
ich nicht hingehe ich gucken kann es
kann von außen immer alles passieren
irgendeinen breaking news ereignet dass
alle vorab breaking news ereignis das
alle forderten vielleicht noch mal
vieles durcheinander wirft wenn das
nicht mehr kommt ein ganz frisches thema
wie afghanistan vor ein paar wochen dann
würde ich denken entscheidend wird sein
wie dicht die union in den nächsten
umfragen die kommen noch mal an die spd
heran kommt wenn das den eindruck macht
am ende das ist in zwei kampf ums
kanzleramt
dann wird sich sicher mit sicherheit
noch einiges verschieben aber da sind
wir an auch nicht dennoch liegt die spd
nach den letzten umfragen auch unserer
letzten umfrage recht deutlich vor der
union aber im schlussspurt kann sich in
der tat noch viel verändern das haben
wir übrigens auch in den letzten
landtagswahlen so erlebt dass wir
verschiebungen hatten gerade in den
letzten 10 14 tagen dass sich leute da
um entscheiden und wir haben anders als
vor zehn 20 30 40 jahren viel weniger
feste wähler bindungen an einzelne
parteien die leute sind bereit wechsel
zu wählen und ich glaube auch gerade
dass diese junge gruppe der bis
50-jährigen sich jetzt so gezielt
informationen holt ganz offensichtlich
spricht dafür die wollen wirklich wissen
wer es mir da am nächsten und wem gebe
ich meine stimme weil sie nicht
selbstverständlich immer das gleiche
wählen und das ist für uns als
journalistinnen und journalisten
natürlich auch eine super chance und
herausforderung und verweise ich an
dieser stelle sehr gerne auf die nächste
politbarometer zahlen die gibt es am
freitag richtig da gibt es den neuen
zahlen werden sie da sein genau und ich
möchte gerne noch mal aufrufen ist es
total spannend wenn ihr schreibt welche
partei für euch die beste ist und wo ihr
euer kreuz machen wollte das bringt uns
aber hier in der sendung nicht so
wirklich weiter hier also eure fragen an
frau professor rummel und matthias
formuliert dann wäre das sehr schön dann
greife ich das natürlich sehr gerne auf
frau professor emil hat dann gebe ich
die kristallkugel mal an sie weiter was
erwartet uns in den nächsten zwei wochen
was glauben sie ja
es bleibt wahnsinnig spannend
nicht also es ist jeder tag jetzt ein
wahltag wir wählen nicht am 26 september
der 26 september ist der letzten tag an
dem wir wählen können was es ja für die
parteien so wahnsinnig schwierig macht
ihren wahlkampf darauf abzustimmen zu
mobilisieren was wir jetzt auch sehen
ist das kampagnen dass wahlkämpfe einen
unterschied machen die art und weise wie
ich wahlkampf führe dass merkels vor
allem an der spd die sich eben schon
seit letztem august auf diesem wahlkampf
vorbereitet hat weil da der kandidat
schon fest stand die der wahlkampf der
union
sehr spät entwickelt er fängt jetzt
nicht es ist wir haben sie ja gerade
auch in den in den daten gesehen herford
hat darauf auch schon hin gewesen die
bäder sind wahnsinnig volatil
das heißt es kann noch einiges passieren
aber
damit sich die lage noch ändert also die
union nahe an die spd dran kommt oder
sie vielleicht noch überholt brauche es
mehr als einen wahlkampf der jetzt
verfängt von seiten der union es braucht
einen
spd-kandidaten der fehler macht und auch
noch einig wie wir sagen ein externer
schock ein externes ereignis das die
lage noch mal ganz herum dreht aber all
das hatten wir auch schon in wahlkämpfen
insofern bleibt die situation die lage
spannend bis zum schluss was natürlich
auch einen extrem mobilisierenden
charakter für die wählerinnen und wähler
hat weil je länger das rennen ist desto
mehr leute gehen tendenziell auch zur
wahl haben sie schon gewählt frau müller
ich habe schon gewählt ja sie sind
briefwählerinnen wie so viele in diesen
zeiten die auch genau jetzt in diesem
zeitraum zwei wochen vor der wahl ihr
kreuz machen deshalb sind natürlich auch
die zeit punkte für dieses tree l und
diese sendung natürlich auch besonders
spannend matthias du wirst die sendung
am wahlabend moderieren das ist beileibe
nicht deine erste du hast schon viele
wahlsendungen bestritten diese wird
besonders spannend werden rechnest du
damit dass er eine lange nacht vor euch
habt und das uns dann auch lange zähe
koalitionsverhandlungen bevor stehen
materielles gemeinsam mit bettina
schausten ja schon seit einigen jahren
das kann man jetzt so noch nicht
vorhersagen ich glaube dass es am ende
noch sehr knapp werden kann und dass wir
dann auch in der zeit reinlaufen wo die
frage wer mit wem regiert noch mal ganz
neu sortiert wird also anders als wir es
im moment diskutieren es gibt ja auch
modelle von minderheitsregierungen es
gibt modelle dass jemand der als
zweitstärkster rauskommt sich trotzdem
eine mehrheit organisieren kann also wir
müssen nicht so starke nur auf die
modelle gucken die wir jetzt kennen aus
den letzten jahren ich glaube schon da
können wir noch überrascht werden ob es
reicht für eine zweierkoalition wie zum
beispiel rot grün das sieht im moment
eher nicht so aus wenn überhaupt
zweierkoalition wer ist wieder die große
koalition und die will wenn man ehrlich
ist eigentlich niemand also läuft man
wahrscheinlich auf ein dreierbündnis hin
dass bei den bürgerinnen und bürgern
sowieso nicht besonders beliebt ist du
hast ja vorhin die zahlen christina
gezeigt mit 33 prozent zustimmung für
das beliebteste dieser drei modelle das
heißt man muss wirklich sehen wie sich
das sortiert wenn man jetzt mal gesehen
hat in körpersprache aber auch in
aussagen wie sich die grünen zur spd
verhalten haben gestern im trial dann
hatte man schon das gefühl dass da
erkennbar eine größere nähe war als zur
cdu auch das kann ein faktor werden am
ende da lassen wir uns überraschen ich
glaube nicht unbedingt dass das in der
wahlnacht sich schon entscheidet da du
zur wahl sendungen in berlin sein willst
dich du hast auch schon briefwahl
gemacht oder wisst ihr noch machen oder
wie ist das wenn jemand hier das ist ja
fast schon zur guten gewohnheit geworden
für mich klar macht briefwahl habe es
auch schon gemacht weil ich an dem
wahlsonntag mich dabei übrigens wenn ich
das sagen darf wir rechnen damit dass
die zahl der briefwähler explodieren
wird sie war letztes mal vor vier jahren
bei etwa 27 prozent wenn ich es richtig
weiß das kann sich glatt verdoppeln das
hat verschiedenste gründe einer davon
ist natürlich die korona pandemie
nachdem die leute jetzt anderthalb jahre
lang gelernt haben dass sie lieber
abstand halten sollen ist ein wahllokal
keine besonders attraktive adresse und
damit werden wir leben müssen das
verändert auch die dramaturgie von so
einem wahlabend weil man natürlich zum
beispiel bei der prognose die die
forschungsgruppe wahlen für uns macht
die wir dann um 18 uhr veröffentlichen
da fragt man ja an den wahllokalen
menschen da hat man ja keine briefwähler
mehr und das macht es alles für uns
schwieriger weil weil sozusagen die das
elektrorad der brief wählerinnen und
wähler durchaus nicht deckungsgleich ist
mit dem der der menschen die am
wahllokal wählen
insofern ist es für die demoskopen wenn
so viele briefwähler da sind auch ein
schwierigeres spiel ich bin sehr
gespannt darauf vielen dank matthias
eine allerletzte frage möchte ich gern
noch unterbringen frau professor emele
markus k fragt über youtube wenn ich
ehrlich bin bin ich mit keiner
bundestagspartei wirklich zufrieden und
eigentlich möchte ich lieber eine kleine
partei wählen verschenke ich so meine
stimme das ist eine frage die sich vor
allem viele junge wählerinnen und wähler
stellen was ist die antwort
nein seine stimme verschenkt man nicht
wir sind in einer demokratie in der nach
einem verhältniswahlrecht gewählt wird
das heißt jede partei wenn sie denn die
fünf-prozent-hürde schafft ist im
parlament vertreten ist das erste die
zweite frage ist ja okay ist sie in der
opposition oder ist indien in der
regierung opposition ist nicht immer
mist opposition ist ganz wichtige und
ganze zentrale parlamentsarbeit ich es
wollte es noch klar professor rummel
wenn ich wenn ich eins ergänzen
beziehungsweise korrigieren darf ich
glaube tatsächlich der user meint
kleinstparteien also nicht die kleinen
also kleiner haben mai im sinn von
klitzeklein also die
tiere
jetzt gerade im schlagabtausch gesehen
habe ja ich meine wenn jeder so denken
würde mit der kleinstpartei dass ich
meine stimme her gebe dann kann es diese
partei ja nie über die fünf prozent
schaffen aber klar ist es so dadurch
dass wir die fünf prozent hürde haben
ist die wahrscheinlichkeit dass diese
kleinstpartei eben nicht repräsentiert
wird relativ groß
also verschenke ich so meine stimme ja
oder nein
nein nein wenn man verschenkt seine
stimme nicht aber man schenkte ihnen
jemand der nicht repräsentiert wird
vielen dank frau professor matthias
fornoff dass sie und dass du heute abend
in dieser sendung mit dabei war es ihnen
und euch
noch spannende zwei wochen und an euch
sie beide vielen dank bis hierhin und
wir machen noch weiter mit einem
kollegen aus unserer redaktion der sich
mit den fakten beschäftigt denn auch
dazu kamen ganz ganz viele fragen über
den chat und viele sachen die in der
sendung gesagt wurden bedürfen natürlich
der überprüfung und deshalb sind wir
sehr früh sehr sehr froh dass thomas
reichert auch heute abend wieder bei uns
in der sendung ist da ist thomas
reichert es ist genauso fast genau so
spät wie gestern nicht ganz aber du hast
auch heute aufmerksam zugeguckt und dich
damit beschäftigt inwiefern denn die
teilnehmenden die wahrheit gesagt haben
sabine pühl schreibt über
per e mail schade dass das zdf nicht mit
statistiken arbeitet dann würde ziemlich
schnell deutlich werden wo wahrheit und
lüge liegen bevor wir in die
beantwortung der faktencheck fragen
gehen kannst du ganz kurz erklären wie
ihr arbeitet
wir haben wir sitzen mit 45 kollegen
zusammen schauen die sendung an wie alle
anderen zuschauer auch und werden
hellhörig wenn politiker sich mit
aussagen festlegen wurde mache auch
gewagte behauptungen aufstellen wo wir
ein bisschen stellen holzen die wir den
politbetrieb ja jeden tag von berlin aus
verfolgen dass wir auch jetzt so wir
haben genau hingehört haben uns dann
gegenseitig auf bestimmte themen
aufmerksam gemacht das war nicht immer
ganz gleich verteilt muss man sagen
zwischen den beteiligten wieder waren
alles weiter wie von der ard die lag da
schon etwas vorne bei den aussagen mobil
ausgehorcht haben aber das ist unsere
arbeit wir wir hören die sendung wir
gucken uns das genau an und
recherchieren dann ein erster
zwischenstand kann ihr euch jetzt schon
geben alle weiteren aussagen wie wir
gecheckt haben wie findet ihr dann
spätestens morgen früh dann auf der
website von heute de dann fangen wir mal
mit einem statement an von alice weidl
zum thema klima das habt ihr euch
genauer angeguckt und zu welchem
ergebnis seite gekommen
und hat gesagt dass sozusagen bezogen
auf die aus die
alternativen energieträger auf den
energiebedarf der durch winterräder
gedeckt hat muss sagte sich diesmal
schnell hier um den energiebedarf zu
decken sind
350.000 windkraftwerke erforderlich geht
übrigens ein viertel der fläche
deutscher sein lehrer thomas du hast
jetzt ganz wunderbar vorgetragen aber
wir haben sogar die möglichkeit ist als
o ton und sagen wir anzugucken und dass
man umso besser um den energiebedarf zu
decken
sind
350.000 windkraftwerke erforderlich die
im übrigen ein viertel der fläche
deutschlands einnehmen und das muss doch
einfach mal mit dazu gesagt werden und
wenn dann der wind nicht bläst dann
steht dann steht hier sowieso alle still
und das steht den leuten sagen es wird
nicht funktionieren
wahr oder falsch
das ist nicht richtig
ein viertel der fläche deutschlands 50
natürlich enorm wenn man stellt sich da
in deutschland vor und machte so sagen
wie bei kuchen ein viertel weg und
stellt sich da leute und windräder vor
das stimmt so nicht zum hintergrund es
gibt eine studie des umweltbundesamtes
die ende 2019 feststellt wie viele
windräder brauchen wir den aktuellen wie
viel fläche brauchen die windräder die
wir aktuell in deutschland haben das
sind aktuell 0,9 prozent der fläche
deutschlands so nur dann bedeutet aber
der
energiewandel und auch die
herausforderungen des klimawandels
bedeuten dass wir viel viel mehr
windenergie brauchten dann auch dafür
gibt es berechnungen gehen davon aus
dass diese um den anteil von 65 prozent
der erneuerbaren energien bis 2030 zu
erreichen müsste der strom aus windkraft
und photovoltaik um das fünf bis sieben
fall steigen also das bedeutet wir
brauchen dann auch ein bisschen mehr
fläche aber das ist deutlich deutlich
weniger als drei mal so gesagt hat bin
maximale verbrauch wird etwa bei knapp
14 prozent liegen aber da gehören dann
auch andere flächen dazu die nicht
genutzt werden können wir müssen also
von weniger ausgehen und selbst damit
ist das noch ein vielfaches dessen was
man tat braucht kurz gesagt vor beide
übertreibt da
maßlos der eigentliche flächenbedarf für
regenerative energie deutlich niedriger
sein aber wird fläche brauchen und auch
neue flächen in deutschland dass es die
andere wahrheit die dazugehört paul
glasmacher fragt über youtube ihr nennen
könnt mit welchen quellen ihr
recherchiert des umweltbundesamt hast du
gerade genannt was nutzt ihr noch als
quellen für euren faktencheck
wir versuchen als nach dem klassischen
handwerk der eines gut und recht wissen
möglichst an die quellen heran zu gehen
hat content immer so sagt einer das wird
auf die quellen zurückgreifen die
besonders glauben wir dass amtliche
quellen wie das statistische bundesamt
dass studien von renommierten zum teil
staatlichen instituten wie das
umweltbundesamt
es sind aber auch forschungsinstitute
darauf versuchen wir zurückzugreifen um
tatsächlich möglichst hart zu prüfen ob
die fakten wie die politiker in ihren
reden in ihren statements nennen auch
wirklich so stimmen wie sie dargestellt
werden das eine ist natürlich dass
manche aussagen gar nicht stimmen wie
bei frau beide leben das andere ist das
nicht aus sagen manchmal so halt stimmen
oder dass ein bestimmter wichtiger
anderer sachverhalt dabei weggelassen
wird mit der absicht das natürlich eine
aussage auch ein ganz gut in den kram
passen kann und den richtigen spindler
hat wie man für die eigene agenda dann
nutzen kann auch darauf schauen wir und
versuchen dann das ganze bild zu zeigen
damit diese aussage auch wirklich im
kontext verstanden werden so das ist die
idee von unseren shack team und ich
glaube das ist gerade jetzt in dieser
heißen phase des wahlkampfs besonders
wichtig ja wir sehen auch dass hier im
chat die diskussionen sowohl um die
inhalte als auch darüber was fakten sind
und was nicht gerade ordentlich an fahrt
aufnimmt also das thema beschäftigt die
leute in der tat sehr greifen wir
nochmal ein zweites beispiel heraus
markus blume der csu-generalsekretär hat
sich zum bundestag geäußert
muss der bundestag so groß sein
es war leider nicht möglich über alle
parteien hinweg zu einer
wahlrechtsreform zu kommen das ist
sicherlich eine aufgabe mit der sich
auch der künftige bundestag beschäftigen
muss
tja thomas zu welchem ergebnis kommt ihr
da das ist ja ein weites feld die größe
des bundestages und die gescheiterte
reform
also mit musst du mir sicher recht hat
ist der letzte teil seiner es soll dass
sich der neue bundestag damit auch
beschäftigen muss
das ist nicht möglich war über alle
parteien hinweg einen konsens zu
erreichen wie er sagt das lag und das
gehört eben auch dazu zu einem großen
teil an der csu die sich vehement und
über einen langen zeitraum gegen eine
wirkliche wahlrechtsreform gewährt hat
es gab das hintergrund der bemühungen
insbesondere auch von den drei
oppositionsparteien
linke fdp und den grünen
was schon mal einigermaßen erstaunlich
ist dass die wirklich zusammenarbeiten
wenn man heute war ein schlager aus
gesehen hat wie kubicki frau bist wisst
ja dazu sagen miteinander agiert haben
dann steht man schon wie ungewöhnlich
ist dass der linke und fdp tatsächlich
zusammengearbeitet haben bei diesem
antrag der bei der leidensdruck offenbar
so groß sie haben ebenfalls versucht zu
verhindern dass der bundestag immer
größer wird einen anderen vorschlag
vorgelegt unser vorschlag ist von der
großen koalition von union und spd
abgelehnt worden die haben sich dann im
spätsommer 2020 selbst noch an
zusammengesetzt als der druck aus der
öffentlichkeit und die perspektive
darauf dass auch der neue bundestag noch
viel größer werden wird noch als
zusammengesetzt das hauptproblem damit
es vielleicht ganz kurz und grob
erklären kann ist dass das der als
direktkandidat gewählt wird auf jeden
fall ein platz den bundestag hat der es
ist ein wahlkreis gewählt ist im
parlament und oft ist es so dass eine
partei mehr wahlkreise gewinnt als sie
vielleicht insgesamt an prozenten
gewinnt dann gibt s sowie an die
überhangmandate gibt dann bei anderen
parteien der gerechtigkeit halber durch
ausgleichsmandaten wieder ausgibt ihnen
werden versorgt wieder so eine art
pinkowski dazu dass das der bundestag
immer größer das soll beendet werden die
große koalition hat dann dein spät für
meinen vorschlag vorgelegt der aber
nicht besonders wirksam ist und der
insbesondere
für die csu bedeutet dass sie weiter
ihre ganzen wahlkreise und direktmandate
der alten kann das war der csu besonders
wichtig
und das hat sie in gewisser weise da
auch erreicht sie hat also im grunde und
das ist die ganze geschichte hinter
dieser aussage von der csu genauso
kreiert dass da eben
die ihre ihr zugriff auf die
direktmandat in bayern die sie in der
regel alle wurde jedenfalls die
allermeisten gewinnt dass sie den weiter
behält dann thomas wissen wir dass der
nächste bundestag schon mal sehr groß
sein wird wer dann am ende drin sitzen
wird das wissen wir am sonntag in einer
woche bis dahin lieber thomas vielen
dank für eure faktencheck expertise auch
in dieser sendung wieder danke dass er
dazu beigetragen habt ein bisschen
klarheit in die dinge zu bringen danke
fürs mitmachen und auch ihnen zu hause
sage ich an dieser stelle vielen dank
dass sie dabei waren und einen schönen
abend und bis zum nächsten mal